Happy New Year, everyone.
祝大家新年快乐。
Josh and Craig here.
我是Josh，我是Craig。
We are taking this week off to ring in the New Year, but we don't want to leave you without an episode to ring it in with.
我们这周休息来迎接新年，但我们不想让大家在跨年时没有节目可听。
So we are replaying, repeating, re...
所以我们重播、重复、重……
We just, it's a rerun, let's just call it.
我们只是，这就是个重播，我们就直说吧。
Let's say what it is.
我们就直说吧。
We don't want to disrespect you on this.
我们不想在这件事上敷衍大家。
We're rerunning a great episode from season one called The Limo.
我们要重播第一季中非常棒的一集，叫《加长轿车》。
We hope you enjoy it.
希望你们喜欢。
We loved revisiting this episode.
我们很喜欢重温这一集。
episode.
这一集。
It was hard to shoot.
拍摄过程很艰难。
We remember.
我们还记得。
But it turned out great.
但最终效果很棒。
And what else?
还有什么呢？
What else to say about the limo, Craig?
关于《加长轿车》，还有什么要说的吗，Craig？
It's one of our own.
这是我们自己的作品。
I mean, it's, we didn't do any years of episode every year.
我的意思是，我们并没有每年都做跨年集。
I don't think we had one season two, for example.
我觉得第二季好像就没有。
So it's kind of it's cool.
所以这挺酷的。
It's I love this one very much, not Moby.
我非常喜欢这一集，不是Moby那一集。
There are so many things in this episode.
这一集里有很多东西。
It's our only episode.
这是我们唯一的一集。
I think that takes place almost exclusively in a limo, which we thought would be easy to shoot and was a nightmare to shoot.
我想它几乎完全是在一辆加长轿车里拍摄的，我们本以为拍摄会很容易，结果却是一场噩梦。
So please enjoy us, remembering what a nightmare it was to shoot and the amazing episode came out of it.
所以请欣赏我们回忆当时拍摄是多么像一场噩梦，以及最终呈现出的精彩剧集。
Hi guys, my name is Andrea, I'm from Mexico and I really do love the episode about the limo.
大家好，我叫Andrea，来自墨西哥，我真的很喜欢《加长轿车》那一集。
I've actually watched it every single New Year's Eve right after 12th and honestly the funny thing is New Year's Eve is like my least favorite holiday of all but I don't know this episode just says to me what's important about a holiday you know like it's not about what party you go to or about gifts or about you know make it extraordinary but about the people you actually spend it with about reflecting about being thankful for one another and I don't know I guess that's just one of the things that I love the most about the show that it makes you come back to the people you love and making sure you spend the most time as possible.
事实上，每个新年前夜午夜过后我都会看这一集，老实说，有趣的是，新年前夜是我最不喜欢的节日，但我不知道，这一集对我来说诠释了节日的意义，你知道，它不在于你去参加什么派对，不在于礼物，也不在于让它变得多么非凡，而在于你真正陪伴的人，在于反思，在于彼此感恩，我不知道，我想这就是我最喜欢这部剧的原因之一，它让你回归到你所爱的人身边，确保你尽可能多地花时间。
You can with them and cherish each other.
你可以和他们在一起，珍惜彼此。
Thank you so much for doing this podcast.
非常感谢你们制作这个播客。
This is amazing.
这太棒了。
So thank you and thank you for changing my life for the better.
所以谢谢你们，谢谢你们让我的生活变得更美好。
I'm alone, won't be soon.
我孤身一人，但很快就不会了。
You know York City, when I see you.
你知道纽约市，当我见到你时。
Please permit me to tell you everything, York City.
请允许我告诉你一切，纽约市。
Well, hello, welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收看《老爸老妈浪漫史》的另一集。
I'm Josh Radner and I am joined by my friend Craig Thomas.
我是Josh Radner，和我在一起的是我的朋友Craig Thomas。
Hello, Craig.
你好，Craig。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，Josh。
Hi.
嗨。
I almost cry every time at the openings now.
我现在每次听到片头曲都快要哭了。
I know.
我知道。
I'm going to produce your aliquets together.
我要把你们的片段剪辑在一起。
I literally almost start to cry every time.
我真的每次都快要哭出来了。
Andrea, I kind of thought, it's so beautiful.
Andrea，我当时想，这太美了。
We could just play that letter.
我们直接播放那封信就好了。
It's like, that's pretty much the episode in some way.
这在某种程度上几乎就是那一集的内容。
She summed it up.
她总结得太好了。
So thank you for joining us on today's episode.
感谢大家收听今天的节目。
It was just to be the shortest one.
这本来应该是最短的一集。
So if you're just tuning in, Andrea from Mexico, which I just love that letter.
所以如果你刚加入我们，来自墨西哥的安德烈亚，我真的很喜欢那封信。
Thank you so much for that, Andrea.
非常感谢你，安德烈亚。
She was talking about episode 11 of how I met your mother.
她谈到了《老爸老妈浪漫史》的第11集。
I'm getting confused about titles.
我总是搞混剧名。
Like I say, how I made your mother, made your mother very tricky.
就像我说的那样，《老爸老妈浪漫史》，老爸老妈，真的很绕口。
But on this podcast, we are doing a rewatch.
但在本播客中，我们正在重温这部剧。
I played Ted Mosby on the show from, what was it, 2005 to 2014?
我在剧中饰演泰德·莫斯比，从2005年到2014年，对吧？
I was in every single episode.
每一集我都有参与。
Craig Thomas probably had a line or two, or every line in many of the episodes.
克雷格·托马斯可能写了一两句台词，或者在很多集里写了每一句台词。
He co-created the show.
他是该剧的联合主创。
I got in two jokes in the series.
我在剧里贡献了两个笑话。
He got in two jokes.
他贡献了两个笑话。
I got two jokes.
我贡献了两个笑话。
He co-created the show with Carter Bayes.
他和卡特·贝斯共同创作了这部剧。
And we're working our way through it, and we're unpacking this mystery of why the show has endured, why people love it so much, why people watch the limo episode every New Year's Eve and what the show just has done to people and continues to do.
我们正在重温这部剧，并试图解开它为何能经久不衰的谜团，为什么人们如此喜爱它，为什么人们每个除夕夜都要看“加长轿车”那一集，以及这部剧对人们产生了怎样的影响并持续产生着影响。
But before we started, we start today, Craig, talking about the limo episode 11.
但在我们开始之前，克雷格，今天我们要聊聊第11集“加长轿车”。
I did want to do a little State of the Union and I just wanted to ask you, how's it going doing this podcast for you?
我确实想做一个简短的“国情咨文”式总结，我想问问你，做这个播客感觉如何？
Oh, I love it.
哦，我太喜欢了。
And you've chosen the perfect moment to do State of the Union because this is episode 11 out of 22, almost all of the seasons were either 22 episodes or 24, 24 in success.
你选择了一个完美的时机来做这个总结，因为这是22集里的第11集，几乎所有的季数要么是22集，要么是24集，成功后变成了24集。
Once we became sort of more of a hit, they're like, give us a couple extra a year.
一旦我们变得更受欢迎，他们就会说，一年多给我们拍几集吧。
And that was a very good sign when I went out to 24.
当增加到24集时，那是一个非常好的信号。
And one year because of the writer's strike in 2007, it was only 20.
有一年因为2007年的编剧大罢工，只有20集。
But so right now we're at the exact midpoint and I am loving it.
但现在我们正好处于中间点，我非常享受这个过程。
I have not watched a lot of these episodes in years, getting to watch it and sort of share it with fans and here like we just did that amazing opening of this episode, here what it means to people, I just find it's so moving.
很多集我已经好几年没看了，现在能重新观看并与粉丝分享，就像我们刚才对这一集开场白所做的那样，听到它对人们意味着什么，我感到非常感动。
It's just, I feel like I'm watching it, I feel like a different person watching it.
我觉得我正在观看它，感觉自己像是一个不同的人在看它。
I was so close to it when we were making it.
制作的时候我离它太近了。
I saw it through such different eyes and I'm loving it, I'm loving it.
我当时是用完全不同的眼光看待它的，我真的很喜欢，我真的很喜欢。
It's wonderful and sort of, I'm marveling at what we did 20 years ago, right?
这太棒了，我对自己20年前所做的事情感到惊叹，对吧？
I can't sort of can't believe a lot of it.
我简直有点不敢相信其中的很多内容。
I'm like, how do we do that?
我在想，我们是怎么做到的？
We didn't know what we're doing.
我们当时根本不知道自己在做什么。
I think when you're in it and you're close to it and an episode's airing six weeks after you just made it, for me, my ego was just tied up in it in a different way than it is now.
我想当你身处其中，离它很近，而且一集剧在制作完成六周后就播出时，对我来说，我的自尊心与它捆绑的方式和现在不同。
I watch it with so much more forgiveness and I'm marveling at the fact that I was involved in this charming show that continues to delight people.
我现在带着更多的宽容去观看，并对这样一个事实感到惊叹：我参与了这部迷人的剧集，它至今仍在给人们带来快乐。
And I just told you, I've just gotten back from the one leg of my tour And I'm meeting all of these people who, you know, just the waitress at the restaurant I was at last night said, I got my whole sense of humor from you.
我刚才告诉你，我刚结束巡演的一站回来，我遇到了很多人，你知道，昨晚我在餐厅遇到的服务员说，我的幽默感全是从你那儿学来的。
It's your wish you don't.
那是你的愿望，你没有。
That's what you said, that's so cool.
你就是这么说的，太酷了。
I said, well, let's see what you got.
我说，好吧，让我看看你有什么本事。
I'll be the judge of that.
我会评判一下的。
Yeah, let's do it.
是的，来吧。
But, you know, I was thinking sometimes, I think that there's a tendency to dismiss TV.
但是，你知道，我有时在想，人们往往会轻视电视。
And I've been guilty of this too, as a kind of a popular medium that maybe, well, I think there's been so much quality television in almost novelistic ways.
我也曾犯过这种错误，认为它只是一种大众媒介，也许……但我认为现在已经有了很多具有小说质感的优质电视剧。
Our show, The Wire, The Sopranos, like TV has really been elevated to high art, but it's also a populist medium, right?
我们的剧，《火线》、《黑道家族》，电视确实已经被提升到了高雅艺术的层面，但它同时也是一种大众媒介，对吧？
It's in everyone's home and now pockets, living rooms.
它进入了每个人的家中，现在是口袋里、客厅里。
But if you think about our human need for story, I'm sure people were stopping Sophocles on the street in the Algora or whatever, and being like, I don't remember what he wrote, but you know what I mean?
但如果你思考一下人类对故事的需求，我相信人们以前也会在广场上拦住索福克勒斯，说，我不记得他写了什么，但你懂我的意思吧？
Like saying like, I think smoking in the banded too is what he wrote.
就像说，我想他写的是《禁止吸烟》之类的。
Not that I'm saying, you know, stopping a playwright agrees to sing the Orestaya Trilogy really floored me.
并不是说，你知道，拦住剧作家去唱《奥瑞斯提亚》三部曲真的让我很震撼。
But I've got a few notes.
但我有几点意见。
Actually an answer for you.
其实有一个答案给你。
Can you sign just, yeah, Elektra on my arm, because I'm gonna get a hat to you.
你能就在我的手臂上签个名吗，就签Elektra，因为我打算去把它纹下来。
That's what people want me to write people while they answer on their arms, they get a tattoo.
人们总是让我给他们写点什么，然后他们就去纹身了。
But I think there is a human, I really maintain there's these human ache for stories.
但我认为人类，我始终坚持认为人类对故事有一种渴望。
We need them.
我们需要它们。
And when people say to me like, this show changed my life, it taught me how to talk with my dad, it got me through my divorce, it gave me my sense of humor.
当人们对我说，这部剧改变了我的人生，它教会了我如何与父亲沟通，它陪我度过了离婚的低谷，它给了我幽默感。
I take that really seriously now, and I really can't, I continue to be moved to have been a part of something that affected people this way.
我现在非常认真地对待这些评价，我真的无法，我依然为能参与到这样影响人们的作品中而感到动容。
But I also, you know, it's so strange to be watching this with my wife and watching almost every episode with her, except this episode we were separate, because I was on tour, but just to look back, it's weird when you do something on camera for this long.
但我也，你知道，和妻子一起看这部剧，几乎每一集都和她一起看，除了这一集我们分开了，因为我在巡演，这种感觉很奇妙，当你长时间在镜头前做一件事时，回首往事的感觉很怪。
It's almost like you have this weird moving in both senses of the word, like photo album of your life.
这就像是你的人生拥有了一本以两种含义呈现的动态相册。
It's like, it's this weird documentary snapshot.
就像是一个奇怪的纪录片快照。
And even though that wasn't what was going on in my life, It was partly what was going on in my life.
尽管那并不是我生活中正在发生的事，但它在某种程度上确实是我生活的一部分。
At least that was my job.
至少那是我的工作。
But most people don't have their jobs filmed and then he's out to the rest of the world.
但大多数人的工作不会被拍摄下来并展示给全世界。
And it feels so weird.
这感觉太奇怪了。
I think about this from your perspective in this rewatch so often.
在这次重温中，我经常从你的角度去思考这个问题。
I'm like, well, Josh knows where he was that day.
我在想，嗯，乔什知道他那天在哪里。
That's him popping out of the top of a limo.
那是他从豪华轿车顶上探出头来。
He's like, that's what I was doing that day of work of my life 20 years ago.
他会想，那就是20年前我那一天的工作内容。
No one gets that and that's you.
没人能体会那种感觉，那就是你。
That's you at that age, at that minute, existing on planet Earth in that moment and watching it again and kind of going back into that.
那是那个年纪、那一分钟的你，在那一刻存在于地球上，再次观看它，就像是回到了过去。
Like, I'm having a little bit of that kind of vertigo of like, I remember I was standing off to the side at Video Village watching the four cameras, you know, the four monitors showing the four camera shots.
就像，我有一种轻微的眩晕感，就像我记得我当时站在视频村（Video Village）旁边，看着那四个监视器，显示着四个摄像机的画面。
But what is it?
但那是什么呢？
Is there kind of like a weird emotional vertigo of trying to like remember your way back into like what it looked like, say within that limo?
是否有一种奇怪的情感眩晕，试图回忆起当时在豪华轿车里是什么样子？
That just occurred to me.
我刚才突然想到了这一点。
I remember, I think sometimes when you're in the apartment or you're in the bar, we did so much in there that it's hard to isolate.
我记得，我想有时当你身处公寓或酒吧时，我们在那里做了太多事，很难单独区分出来。
Oh, I remember that day, unless something really particularly strange happened.
哦，我记得那天，除非发生了什么特别奇怪的事情。
But the limo became shorthand for this prison that we all shared together.
但豪华轿车成了我们共同经历的那个“监狱”的代名词。
Like, I remember us saying limo, like, whatever was going on, we'd be like, well, at least we're not in the limo because it was so intense.
就像，我记得我们说“豪华轿车”时，无论发生什么，我们都会说，好吧，至少我们不在豪华轿车里，因为那里太压抑了。
And I think, remind me, was it all shot in an actual limo or was some of it tricked out, like, to look like a limo?
我想问一下，提醒我一下，它是全程在真正的豪华轿车里拍摄的，还是有些部分是搭建出来看起来像豪华轿车的？
Did we shoot some of it on the stage?
我们是在摄影棚里拍了一些吗？
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
Well, I, it was an episode that Carter was on the set for and he would probably have more memories than me, so I wish we had him on this one.
嗯，卡特当时在片场，他可能比我有更多的记忆，所以我希望他也能参加这一期。
But I think, no, I think we had, we were shooting the inside of the limo.
但我认为，不，我想我们当时是在拍摄豪华轿车的内部。
I think it was, a lot of it was really in that limo, I think, and it was really hard to shoot.
我想很多时候确实是在那辆车里拍的，而且拍摄难度很大。
It was cramped.
空间非常狭窄。
I mean, a lot of times there were like four people in like a three-person back seat.
我的意思是，很多时候后座明明只能坐三个人，却挤了四个人。
I did, I do have very strong memories of, one thing I really loved was how the sunroof kind of area becomes this other playing space.
我确实有非常深刻的记忆，我特别喜欢的一点是天窗区域如何变成了另一个表演空间。
It's like another room.
它就像另一个房间。
Well, it's like stepping out onto the balcony, right?
嗯，就像走到阳台上一样，对吧？
Like it has that feel, and I just love, I remember very strongly like when it was joyful to get out of the limo, kind of get some air and pop up, but I really liked all the scenes that were played up there.
它有那种感觉，我非常喜欢，我清楚地记得当从豪华轿车里出来透透气并探出头来时是多么快乐，我真的很喜欢所有在上面拍摄的场景。
I found it really, and I remember that final scene with Kobe, and maybe it was because it was episode 11, but this episode I think does a very good job, and we'll summarize what the episode is in one second, but it does a very good job of being, like we said, a self-contained episode, you could just tune in and you watch this gang of friends try to navigate this crazy New Year's Eve.
我发现它真的很棒，我记得与科比的最后一场戏，也许是因为那是第11集，但我认为这一集做得非常好，我们待会儿会总结这一集的内容，它做得非常好，就像我们说的，是一个独立的故事，你可以随时收看，看着这群朋友试图度过这个疯狂的新年前夜。
But also the Ted and Robin thing, it's like you move the ball down the field.
还有泰德和罗宾的故事线，就像是让剧情向前推进了一步。
Like it really does that thing you guys were trying to do.
它真的做到了你们想要实现的效果。
You were having your cake and eating it too, I think in a really nice way here.
我觉得你们在这里以一种非常巧妙的方式做到了两全其美。
Yeah, the very end of that episode where he walks across the street and the light changes to like walk as he walks into kind of the future.
是的，那一集的最后，他穿过马路，当他走向未来时，红绿灯变成了通行信号。
I love that shot.
我喜欢那个镜头。
First of all, Pam Fryman.
首先，帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）。
When Pam Fryman would do put together a shot like that, we'd call it, we'd say, that shot was deep fried, the pan-fryment.
当帕姆·弗莱曼构思出这样的镜头时，我们会说，那个镜头是“深炸”的（deep fried），也就是帕姆·弗莱曼式的。
And that is a deep fried shot, that is a classic.
那是一个经典的“深炸”镜头。
And it feels like he's walking into a new year.
感觉他正走进新的一年。
He's walking into a new chapter.
他正走进人生的新篇章。
We don't know what's gonna happen.
我们不知道会发生什么。
It's a great way to say the audience, hey, keep watching.
这是一种告诉观众“嘿，继续看下去”的好方法。
You're gonna see some cool stuff.
你会看到一些很酷的东西。
And it's also, it's a purely cinematic moment.
而且这纯粹是一个电影化的时刻。
Like I'm always looking for moments, like I'm going to quote, I'm going to reference my own work, but in liberal arts, it's, there's this somewhat of a romance, but not quite between a 35-year-old and a 19-year-old.
就像我一直在寻找这样的时刻，我会引用我自己的作品，但在《爱与艺术》中，35岁和19岁之间有一种浪漫，但又不完全是。
And he's obsessed with their age difference as he should be.
他沉迷于他们的年龄差距，这是理所当然的。
And he works out the math.
他算了一笔账。
He says, when I was, you know, 16, she was zero.
他说，我16岁的时候，她才出生。
When I was 19, she was three.
我19岁的时候，她才3岁。
But then he goes, well, when I'm so-and-so she'll be so.
但后来他说，嗯，当我到某某岁时，她会是某某岁。
And then the age starts seeming like less of a problem.
然后年龄看起来似乎就没那么大问题了。
But it's a totally silent scene.
但这完全是一个无声的场景。
And it goes back and forth.
镜头来回切换。
It's just an inner, a close insert shot on the page a page and his face, boom, boom, boom.
这只是一个内心戏，一个特写镜头，在纸张和他的脸之间，砰，砰，砰。
And the thing I loved about that is you cannot do that in a theater.
我喜欢的一点是，你在剧院里是做不到这一点的。
That is a purely like cinematic shot.
那是一个纯粹的电影化镜头。
And I love the last shot of the limo because him walking away with that little grin on his face and the camera pulling up and just catching the go, the pedestrian go sign is that is movie making.
我喜欢加长轿车的最后一个镜头，他带着那抹小小的微笑走开，摄像机升起，刚好拍到行人通行信号灯，这就是电影制作。
Like that is like, it tells you everything you need to know and you feel it in your chest.
这就像，它告诉你所有你需要知道的一切，你能在心里感受到它。
It doesn't, uh, it's not words.
它不需要，呃，它不是靠语言。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这个小日子，送你去纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是Alex Goldman，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我30岁了，但我不敢在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时不能调节车载音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会揭露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《HyperFixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
在任何你收听播客的地方或访问HyperFixedPod.com即可找到。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
And also, I should say, I found this, I looked up some fun facts about this episode.
另外，我应该说，我查到了一些关于这一集的趣事。
Our cinematographer, Chris LaFontaine, won an Emmy for cinematography for this episode.
我们的摄影指导Chris LaFontaine凭借这一集获得了艾美奖最佳摄影奖。
This was his Emmy winning submission.
这就是他获得艾美奖的参赛作品。
And when you watch this one, it really looks beautiful.
当你观看这一集时，它看起来真的很美。
The night stuff outside of New York Street and the ending we just talked about, it's really quite moving to look at.
纽约街头的夜景和我们刚才谈到的结尾，看起来真的很动人。
It's a beautiful, beautifully shot episode.
这是一集拍摄得非常精美的剧集。
It's also hard, I don't think people understand, it's hard to get cameras into a limo and it's hard to light a limo.
这也很难，我不认为人们理解，把摄像机放进加长轿车里很难，给轿车打光也很难。
Like, there were technical challenges.
这确实存在技术挑战。
It's really hard.
真的很难。
That was triumphant in this episode and people don't understand.
这一集取得了成功，但人们并不理解。
I don't think the- Truly, and I will say the irony, We should say, I mean, we've sort of summarized the episode.
我不认为……真的，我想说的是讽刺之处，我们应该说，我的意思是，我们已经总结了这一集。
It's our big New Year's Eve episode.
这是我们盛大的除夕夜特辑。
Ted rents a limo to try to steal back a good New Year's from what is a sea of terrible New Year's Eve.
泰德租了一辆加长轿车，试图从一堆糟糕的除夕夜中挽回一个美好的除夕夜。
New Year's Eve's are often terrible, as Ted says to the coat check girl, and okay, awesome, when they're listening stuff, that's supposed to be fun, that is not.
正如泰德对存衣处女孩所说，除夕夜往往很糟糕，好吧，太棒了，当他们听这些东西时，本该很有趣，但事实并非如此。
New Year's Eve, which is a wonderful sort of setup for Ted saying, okay, we're taking back New Year's Eve tonight, we're gonna make this one fun.
除夕夜，这为泰德说“好吧，我们今晚要夺回除夕夜，我们要让这一晚变得有趣”提供了一个很好的铺垫。
And he tries to do that for his group of friends, but there's this element of Robin dating this new guy who's super rich, and Ted has a date that night, and Ted's date sort of goes away, says you're in love with Robin, which is a great thing to hear in episode 11, the dead middle point of season one, for the wear of the rest of season one's going.
他试图为他的朋友们做到这一点，但罗宾正在和一个超级有钱的新男友约会，而且泰德那天晚上也有约会，泰德的约会对象离开了，说你爱的是罗宾，这在第一季第11集，也就是第一季的中点听到是一件很棒的事，预示了第一季剩余部分的发展。
She leaves, and then Ted and Robin is something gonna happen.
她离开了，然后泰德和罗宾之间会发生什么吗？
No, the billionaire guy comes back, finds Robin.
不，那个亿万富翁回来了，找到了罗宾。
He wasn't supposed to be available that night, kind of gets in Ted's way, but then Ted and Robin have this wonderful moment at the end that promises more.
他本不应该在那晚有空的，这有点阻碍了泰德，但泰德和罗宾在最后有一个美好的时刻，预示着未来。
I will say the ones, all of that summary to say, We tried to make an episode that was simple to shoot.
我想说的是，所有这些总结都是为了说，我们试图制作一集拍摄起来简单的剧集。
That was how this idea came about.
这个想法就是这样产生的。
We had been asking, we've been asking so much of the crew.
我们一直在要求，我们对剧组的要求太多了。
We had been spending too much money.
我们花钱花得太多了。
We had been doing so many 60, 70 episodes that our wonderful producer, Susie Greenberg, who's praises, we were just singing earlier today.
我们拍了太多集，六七十集，以至于我们出色的制片人苏西·格林伯格——我们今天早些时候还在称赞她。
And Pam Fryman and everybody made these episodes happen.
还有帕姆·弗莱曼和大家，是他们让这些剧集得以实现。
And we said, here's our gift to you.
于是我们说，这是我们送给你们的礼物。
We're just gonna make an episode mostly in this limo.
我们打算拍一集大部分场景都在这辆豪华轿车里的戏。
Everybody's together for the most part.
大部分时间大家都在一起。
You're welcome, it's so simple.
不客气，这很简单。
And by the end of shooting this episode, everybody was like, fuck you guys.
结果拍到最后，每个人都觉得，去你们的吧。
You made, this was the hardest one to shoot.
你们拍的这一集，是最难拍的一集。
It was hard.
确实很难。
真的很难。
And I run a little claustrophobic.
而且我有点幽闭恐惧症。
You know, like it was just, it was a real, I remember on breaks when we would have a moment to step out and we'd be like, oh, you know, coming out of the.
你知道，这真的，我记得休息的时候，我们好不容易能出来透口气，我们就会觉得，哦，你知道，从那个……
Yeah, correct me if I'm wrong.
是的，如果我说错了请纠正我。
We drove a limo into the sound stage, made it certain poor man's process as they say, right, just black out the windows and shot it on a soundstage mostly.
我们把一辆豪华轿车开进了摄影棚，用了所谓的“穷人拍摄法”，对吧，就是把窗户遮黑，大部分场景都在摄影棚里拍的。
Only the exterior limo stuff is actually shot on exterior near your street, but the limo that we were shooting in was the same limo question mark, or was it a special limo where it was tricked out to have a different limo where seats lifted out and walls lifted out?
只有豪华轿车的外景是在你们街道附近拍的，但我们拍摄用的那辆豪华轿车是同一辆吗？还是说那是一辆特制的豪华轿车，经过改装，座椅和墙壁都可以拆卸？
I'm sure it was something clever like that, but god damn it, I can't remember.
我肯定那是某种巧妙的设计，但该死，我记不清了。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
I wasn't on set that way.
我当时没在片场。
I do have memory of an actual limo being in stage 22.
我确实记得22号摄影棚里有一辆真正的豪华轿车。
Like we shot.
就像我们拍的那样。
So all the stuff that was inside was shot inside a sound stage in this limo.
所以所有内景都是在摄影棚里的这辆车里拍的。
I don't know if it would have, it was probably a special limo where stuff moved in and out and then the limo that actually you see exterior on the street was not that limo because it was just a normal limo that actually drove and didn't have seats lifted.
我不知道它是不是，它可能是一辆特制的车，里面的东西可以移进移出，而你在街上看到的那个外景车并不是那辆车，因为它只是一辆普通的、能开动且座椅不能拆卸的豪华轿车。
But it was incredibly complicated as it turned out.
但事实证明，这极其复杂。
Yeah, like I said, it became a kind of shorthand, like, well, would you rather go back to the limo?
是的，就像我说的，这成了一种简写，比如，“你宁愿回到那辆豪华轿车里吗？”
It's like, it was supposed to be simpler.
这本来应该是更简单的。
We were a little scarred by it, but I mean, scarred relative to, you know, still a good job.
我们对此有点心理阴影，不过，比起其他工作，这依然是一份好工作。
But I do think you picked up in here the runner of Ted and his schedule.
但我确实认为你在这里捕捉到了泰德和他日程安排的那个梗。
You know, he's like needing to plan his needing to have the like, no, no, no, we're intended to end 45, we're supposed to be at this party.
你知道，他需要计划他的，他需要有那种，“不，不，不，我们打算45分结束，我们应该去参加这个派对。”
But the one person he will deviate from and improvise and go into like, well, let's see what happens is Robin, he will throw, he will tear up the schedule, he will he will chew the schedule and swallow it if robin calls yes yeah which his date very much picks up on by the end yeah it's poor date it was the hugger and guess she's very sweet about it but she's like you're in love with robin and it was just really exciting to hear someone say that to Ted's face in that moment on New Year's Eve it was it I loved that moment because it was like well yeah that's what the rest of the season is going to be about and I thought that was uh I thought it was so funny when he denies it she says you clearly in love with robin And he's like, no, and he's very sincere.
但有一个人能让他偏离计划、即兴发挥，进入那种“好吧，看看会发生什么”的状态，那就是罗宾。如果罗宾打来电话，他会撕掉日程表，他会把日程表嚼碎吞下去。是的，没错。他的约会对象在最后也看出来了。是的，可怜的约会对象，那个拥抱狂，我觉得她对此很贴心，但她说：“你爱着罗宾。”在除夕夜那一刻，听到有人当面那样对泰德说，真的很令人兴奋。我喜欢那一刻，因为那就像是，“好吧，是的，这就是剩下那一季要讲的内容。”我觉得他否认的时候太搞笑了，她说：“你显然爱着罗宾。”而他说：“没有。”而且他非常真诚。
She says, and it's clear she's, she's into you too.
她说：“而且很明显，她也喜欢你。”
And he's like, wait, really?
然后他说：“等等，真的吗？”
Like he can't play that so great.
他那种反应演得太棒了。
He can't not get there.
他无法掩饰。
He's so funny and he's yelling at everybody else for daring to deviate from the schedule.
他太搞笑了，他冲着其他人大喊大叫，责怪他们竟敢偏离日程表。
But anything you're right, anything related to Robin, he's like, all right, we're off book here.
但只要是和罗宾有关的事，他就说：“好吧，我们不按剧本来了。”
Just a shout out to Kathleen Perkins, who played Mary Beth the hugger, the hugging coworker, who was so wonderful.
顺便提一下凯瑟琳·珀金斯，她饰演了拥抱狂玛丽·贝丝，那个爱拥抱的同事，她太棒了。
And also, if you've ever seen the dev show episodes, She was at like a network executive, or like the head of the, yeah.
而且，如果你看过《发展受阻》，她当时演的是一个网络高管，或者说是……
She was so unbelievably funny in that.
她在那里面的表演简直好笑得不可思议。
I remember years later just seeing her crush that show.
我记得多年后看到她在那部剧里的精彩表现。
She was fantastic.
她太棒了。
And had clearly encountered a bunch of executives.
而且显然她遇到过很多高管。
Like she understood the essence of that, yeah.
她抓住了那种精髓，是的。
But I thought it was really funny.
但我当时觉得这真的很有趣。
I was like, well, she hugs me a lot.
我当时想：“好吧，她经常拥抱我。”
Maybe that means she's into me.
“也许这意味着她喜欢我。”
She just, she's constitutionally incapable of not hugging people.
她只是天生就无法克制自己不去拥抱别人。
She has to hug everybody.
她必须拥抱每一个人。
Yeah, it's her thing.
没错，这是她的风格。
Yeah, she was great.
是的，她表现得很棒。
And we should say JP Manu as not Moby was great and iconic in this episode.
我们还应该提到JP·马努，他在这一集里表现得非常出色且具有标志性，他演的不是莫比。
Not Moby has stuck in the culture, I think.
我觉得“非莫比”这个梗已经深入人心了。
Hey, can you tell the story?
嘿，你能讲讲那个故事吗？
Don't you have a real life story about the sort of intersection of reality?
你不是有一个关于现实交汇的真实故事吗？
Well, I know Moby a bit.
嗯，我稍微认识一点莫比。
I mean, if you live in L.A.
我是说，如果你在洛杉矶住得够久，
long enough, you get to know Moby.
你总会认识莫比的。
He's the Richard Kind of L.A.
他就像洛杉矶的理查德·凯恩一样。
He's just, he's around.
他就是，他总是在那儿。
He wasn't Richard Kind also the Richard Kind of L.A.
理查德·凯恩本人不也是洛杉矶的理查德·凯恩吗？
But I ended up I used to go to the East parties when he lived not far from me But then we both moved not long after like three doors down from him So I he was my neighbor I would see him, you know We'd be walking dogs and just have a conversation, but I remember at some point I said hey Do you get do people ever tell you about this how I met your mother episode?
但我后来，我以前常去参加东区的派对，当时他住得离我不远，但后来我们都搬家了，没过多久我就搬到了离他家只有三扇门远的地方。所以他成了我的邻居，我会见到他，你知道的，我们遛狗时会聊聊天，但我记得有一次我说，嘿，人们有没有跟你提过《老爸老妈浪漫史》的那一集？
And he was like yeah all the time And it's funny because when people run into him, I'm sure they're like are you Moby or not Moby?
他说，有啊，经常有人提。这很有趣，因为当人们偶遇他时，我敢肯定他们会问，你是莫比还是“非莫比”？
But he definitely was feeling the I don't think it was a burden, but I think he was feeling like yeah I know this episode is out there.
但他确实感觉到了，我不认为这是一种负担，但我认为他觉得，是的，我知道有这一集存在。
I don't know if he'd ever seen it, but I think he had pieced together what what the gist was It's hilarious.
我不知道他有没有看过，但我认为他已经拼凑出了大概的内容，这太搞笑了。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
What what does that mean?
那是什么意思？
Why are people saying the phrase not Moby to me?
为什么人们会对我说“非莫比”这个词？
Where did you come up with like how how Moby and not Steven Tyler?
你们是怎么想出莫比这个角色的，而不是史蒂芬·泰勒？
Like where did that come from?
那是怎么来的？
I think it was just that we thought it had to be a guy that you could you could You could conceivably get it wrong.
我想是因为我们觉得那必须是一个你可能会认错的人。
Do you know what I mean?
你明白我的意思吗？
Like, Moby had, you do sometimes see guys that look like Moby, right?
就像莫比，你有时确实会看到长得像莫比的人，对吧？
You had that just, Alec Love, our producer.
你刚才提到的，我们的制片人亚历克·洛夫。
Alec looks like Moby.
Alec看起来像Moby。
You could look like Moby, you got the glasses on, you got the sort of like hipster track jumpers.
你也可以看起来像Moby，你戴着眼镜，穿着那种嬉皮士风格的运动衫。
I'm not saying that's what Moby in real life does now, but for a certain time, in the late 90s or early 2000s, there was a very iconic Moby look.
我不是说现实生活中的Moby现在就是那样，但在90年代末或21世纪初的某个特定时期，Moby有一个非常标志性的造型。
There he is, Alex replicating, it was glasses.
你看，Alex在模仿他，就是那副眼镜。
And I think it was just, we were pitching on, who could you plausibly really get into a memo spend a bunch of time with before realizing it's not that person and it just Moby was somehow it was just the platonic ideal idea just was perfect do you know how it's like we were talking in the last episode like the pineapple was the perfect fruit and Moby was the perfect rock star for this rock star yeah oh no some yeah if you spend enough time and you have to sit around for like half a day in a writer's room just pitching on stuff and to land at Moby or to land at Pine Apple and you go I can't believe this is what I'm doing with my life I can't be paid to do this to talk for half a day about who's the best person and like five hours and it's like Moby.
我想当时我们只是在讨论，谁是那种你可以合理地花很多时间在一起，却还没意识到那不是本人的人，而Moby不知怎么地就成了完美的理想人选，就像我们上一集说的，菠萝是完美的水果，而Moby就是这个摇滚明星故事里的完美摇滚明星，是的，如果你在编剧室里花上半天时间讨论这些，最后得出Moby或者菠萝的结论，你会想，我不敢相信我的人生竟然在做这种事，我竟然能拿钱做这种事，花半天时间讨论谁是最合适的人选，讨论了五个小时，最后得出是Moby。
And but then you're glad you spent the time because not Moby was I don't think we could have beaten it.
但后来你会庆幸自己花了这些时间，因为我觉得除了Moby，我们不可能找到更好的了。
That's fantastic.
那太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
It's perfection.
简直完美。
Yeah.
是的。
And it also it also like it made me feel again almost like the balance of action song.
而且它也让我再次感受到了那种动作歌曲的平衡感。
It made me feel like we're on a show of the moment.
它让我觉得我们是在做一档当下的节目。
You know what I mean?
你明白我的意思吗？
Like we're not on a show that's like talking about Lawrence Welk.
就像我们不是在谈论Lawrence Welk那种老掉牙的节目。
Like we're were like really, were really happening in real time.
我们是在实时地发生着什么。
And now it's a period piece.
而现在它成了一部时代剧。
Like now it feels like, okay, we look back.
现在感觉就像，好吧，我们回过头来看。
That was 2005.
那是2005年的事了。
There are a couple of things I wanted to, that just delighted me that I just wanted to say.
有几件事让我非常开心，我一定要说出来。
Barney C.D.
Barney的CD。
is hilarious.
太搞笑了。
And the fact that it should rise and fall, but no, it should just rise and rise and rise.
而且它本该起起落落，但没有，它应该一直上升，不断上升。
And that not Moby agrees with him.
而且假Moby还同意他的观点。
Oh, when they link up about it and not Moby is saying insightful things about music.
哦，当他们因为这件事产生共鸣，而假Moby在谈论音乐时说出那些深刻的见解时。
It's like, clearly this is Moby, he's a music guy.
就像，很明显这就是Moby，他是个音乐人。
He knows everything about music.
他对音乐无所不知。
He's like, he's second and burn.
他就像是，他是第二名，然后被淘汰了。
But, yeah, would say it hard to get the rights to, you give love a bad name?
但是，说真的，拿到《You Give Love a Bad Name》的版权很难吗？
Is that what the song's called?
那首歌叫这个名字吗？
First of all, yeah, that's the song.
首先，是的，就是那首歌。
You give a little bad name.
《You Give a Little Bad Name》。
First of all, I think it's the most we've ever played a song in an episode, because that song starts and stops like 14 times.
首先，我觉得这是我们在单集里播放次数最多的一首歌，因为那首歌在剧里反复播放又停止了大概14次。
I think you have to pay more for that.
我想你为此得付更多的钱。
I wish this would be a good Andy Gamone question.
真希望这能成为安迪·加蒙（Andy Gamone）的一个好问题。
If we ever talked to our music supervisor, Andy Gamone, I think you probably text her.
如果我们能和我们的音乐主管安迪·加蒙聊聊，我觉得你可能会给她发短信。
You're like, we're gonna play it 15 times.
你会说，我们要播放15次。
Is that okay?
这样可以吗？
I think there's probably an upcharge there.
我想这大概会有额外收费。
But it was expensive.
但它确实很贵。
It was probably our most expensive one today, where it's a Bon Jovi.
这可能是我们目前为止最贵的一首歌，毕竟是邦·乔维（Bon Jovi）的歌。
It's an absolute classic Bon Jovi song.
这绝对是邦·乔维的经典之作。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
It was a lot of money.
确实花了很多钱。
But you wanna know something talking about spending half a day debating Moby.
但你想知道关于花半天时间争论莫比（Moby）的事吗？
I cannot tell you how much of a debate there was about what song this should be.
我无法告诉你我们为了这首歌到底争论了多久。
It had to be a song that right when you hit play, it's just all the way in.
它必须是一首你一按下播放键，就立刻进入状态的歌。
It's all the way in.
完全进入状态。
There's no slow build.
没有缓慢的铺垫。
There's no intro piece.
没有前奏部分。
It's right.
就是直接开始。
It has to be a song that starts And Phil Lord and I, it's probably the closest we've come to actually having discord in our relationship because Phil Lord, whom I adore, Lord Miller, they were writers on the show on season one, Phil was going to die on the hill of any way you want it by a journey, is that what that song's called?
它必须是一首一开头就……菲尔·洛德（Phil Lord）和我，这可能是我们关系中最接近产生分歧的一次，因为我崇拜的菲尔·洛德，还有米勒（Lord Miller），他们是第一季的编剧，菲尔当时坚持要用Journey乐队的《Any Way You Want It》，那首歌是叫这个名字吗？
You know when you, the song comes in, it's like, any way you want, yeah, that's what, yeah.
你知道当那首歌响起时，就像是“Any way you want”，对，就是那个，没错。
And it comes in so hot, just like shot through the heart.
它一出来就非常火爆，就像“shot through the heart”一样。
Like it comes, it's another song that comes in like that.
就像它一样，这是另一首以那种方式开场的歌。
got whittled down to this like death match between those two songs.
最后缩减成了这两首歌之间的生死决斗。
And we were almost shouting at each other about like, and I was of the moment, Bon Jovi, you know, I was like a teenager preteen at that moment.
我们当时几乎是在互相大喊大叫，而我当时正处于邦·乔维的那个阶段，你知道，我那时还是个十几岁的少年。
That song just hit at that point for me much more than journey was, you know, 10, 15 years before that.
那首歌在那时对我来说比Journey乐队的歌更有冲击力，毕竟那是早了10到15年的歌。
And so I think I think I might have made the final call, like it's got to be, it's got to be done.
所以我认为可能是我做了最终决定，就选这首，必须是这首。
I do remember in the network run through, I think Dave Bakers was was just pressing play every time you know off and I do remember it killing like it's funny every time and it gets funnier and it's also like when Kobe starts singing it when Robin's been singing it trying to amp up the car is so funny that would be also a good Andy Galant we should have Andy Galant on to talk about we should do an Andy Galant episode it'd be very funny to say when when Robin starts singing it was that another 15,000 How much did we pay for that?
我确实记得在电视台的试播中，戴夫·贝克斯（Dave Bakers）每次都按下播放键，我记得每次都笑死人了，而且一次比一次好笑，还有当科比（Kobe）开始唱，罗宾（Robin）也跟着唱试图活跃车内气氛时，真的太搞笑了，这也可以问问安迪·加兰特（Andy Galant），我们应该请安迪·加兰特来聊聊，我们应该做一期安迪·加兰特的专题，当罗宾开始唱的时候，那是不是又要多付15000美元？我们到底付了多少钱？
Yeah, how much did we pay for her just to sing it?
是啊，我们付了多少钱让她唱那一段？
Yeah, I think you have to.
是啊，我想你必须得付。
I think it's, yeah, we got to ask him that.
我想，是的，我们得问问他。
I'm almost positive we would have had to pay for that too.
我几乎可以肯定我们也得为此付费。
But it's just, it's the perfect song.
但它确实是完美的歌曲。
It comes in on 11.
它一出来就是满格音量。
It just comes in, it comes in in the red.
它直接就爆表了。
Yeah, well also there's music, like needle drops, which is an industry term, but they're so important.
是的，而且还有音乐，比如“插曲”（needle drops），这是行业术语，但它们非常重要。
It's so important, sometimes you can introduce a song like you love, like not a surf, which maybe a lot of people hadn't heard.
这太重要了，有时你可以介绍一首你喜欢的歌，比如《Not a Surf》，可能很多人都没听过。
This is one, it's dependent on it being in the cultural bloodstream for 20 years.
但这首歌不同，它依赖于在文化血液中流传了20年的背景。
You need something that everyone, that's part of the comedy about it, is it's just like, it just does the thing it's supposed to do, and it also does it at moments that it's inappropriate.
你需要一首大家都熟悉的歌，这也是喜剧效果的一部分，它就是能起到预期的作用，而且它总是在不合时宜的时刻出现。
Yeah.
没错。
Oh, there's when there's like the awkward sort of downbeat silence and then it pops in again.
哦，还有那种尴尬的低沉沉默，然后它又突然响起来的时候。
That was a laugh out loud moment for me watching it.
看的时候我真的忍不住大笑。
And also that Barney's entire psyche is like as soon as that CD is to get like mixed goes away, he becomes Emily Dickinson.
还有巴尼（Barney）的整个心理状态，一旦那张CD被拿走，他就变得像艾米莉·狄金森（Emily Dickinson）一样。
He doesn't have any where he just spirals into darkness, which is almost like it's his drug for the night.
他没有任何缓冲，直接陷入黑暗，这对他来说就像是当晚的毒品。
Like it's his way to stay psyched.
就像这是他保持兴奋的方式。
And once he has it, he falls into an existential pit.
一旦他得到了，他就会陷入存在主义的深渊。
So is this the first Ranji reappearance since the pilot?
所以这是兰吉自试播集以来的首次回归吗？
Yes, Ranji appeared in two episodes in season one episode one pilot episode 11 the lima.
是的，兰吉在第一季中出现过两集，第一集试播集和第11集《豪华轿车》。
Okay, there it is Wow, it's so funny how sometimes characters like loom large in the psyche of the show But like yeah, I mean, it's amazing that he was only on two He has so much presence.
好吧，原来如此。哇，真有趣，有时候像这样的角色在剧集的心理层面占据了很大的比重，但说真的，他只出现了两次，这太令人惊讶了，他的存在感太强了。
He's just present on screen and he was also the kindest sweetest human like every time I'm you were never not delighted to see Marshall come on set.
他出现在屏幕上就很有存在感，而且他也是那种最善良、最可爱的人，每次……你看到马歇尔来到片场总是会感到很高兴。
He was so wonderful.
他真是太棒了。
I also love, I don't want you to see me pissed.
我也喜欢那句“我不想让你看到我生气”。
I love that.
我喜欢那句。
I don't want his to be pissed, Ted.
我不想让他生气，泰德。
It's so great.
太棒了。
He's like, he struck up a friendship.
他就像是，他建立了一段友谊。
You know what I mean?
你明白我的意思吗？
He's a gentleman.
他是个绅士。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
Was Ranjit driving for the limo company and Ted found him?
兰吉当时是在为豪华轿车公司开车，然后被泰德找到了吗？
Did Ted rent a limo and hire Ranjit to be the driver?
是泰德租了豪华轿车并雇佣兰吉当司机的吗？
Like, how does this work?
这到底是怎么运作的？
And how did Ted track him down?
泰德是怎么找到他的？
Do we just assume at the end of that champagne night, they were like, let's all stay in touch.
我们是不是只能假设在那个香槟之夜结束时，他们说“让我们保持联系”？
Yeah, let's all stay in touch.
是的，让我们保持联系。
They probably let's let's all buy a bar type of moment.
他们可能就像那种“让我们一起买个酒吧”的时刻。
I think, yeah, it's definitely strongly implied that Ranchi now drives for the limo company too, because he says, I'm moving up in the world.
我想，是的，这绝对强烈暗示了兰吉现在也为那家豪华轿车公司开车，因为他说“我正在步步高升”。
He's moving up from cab to driving a big old limo for special events.
他从开出租车升级到为特殊活动驾驶大型豪华轿车了。
A couple other things.
还有几件事。
This is the first time I ever heard the phrase, and I love it, but when Lily said these dogs are barking, was that a Courtney Kain line?
这是我第一次听到这个短语，我很喜欢，但当莉莉说“这些狗在叫”（脚疼）时，那是考特尼·凯恩的台词吗？
I feel like that might have been a Courtney Kain line.
我觉得那可能是考特尼·凯恩的台词。
That is an old, that phrase pre-exists.
那是一个古老的短语，早就存在了。
That is my new hero.
那是我的新偶像。
No, I know it existed.
不，我知道它早就存在。
But I've never heard it before.
但我以前从未听过。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Was did Courtney pitch it?
是考特尼提议的吗？
I can see Courtney pitching that.
我能想象考特尼提议的样子。
God, I can't remember.
天哪，我不记得了。
I love these dogs.
我喜欢这些狗。
I love when Lily would just say weird shit, like these dogs are barking.
我喜欢莉莉说些奇怪的话，比如“这些狗在叫”。
These dogs are barking, yeah.
这些狗在叫，没错。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
Natalia is great.
娜塔莉亚很棒。
The drunk.
那个醉鬼。
Very funny.
非常有趣。
I super love you.
我超级爱你。
She was, she, I mean, sometimes guest stars.
她，我的意思是，有时候客串明星。
It's actually very hard to guest star on a show Because we, the five of us, we live there, right?
在剧集中客串其实非常困难，因为我们五个人，我们住在那里，对吧？
They're coming into our house.
他们是走进我们的家。
We know the whole crew, it's the warmth that you feel and the ease and comfort you feel when you're a series regular is so different than what a guest art feels.
我们认识所有的工作人员，那种作为常驻演员所感受到的温暖、轻松和舒适，与客串演员的感受是完全不同的。
They get cast very quickly.
他们很快就被选角了。
They go into a wardrobe fitting.
他们去试装。
They're on to that.
他们很快就进入状态了。
Maybe the next, that afternoon or the next day or two days later, maybe they haven't even been, I don't remember.
也许是第二天，那天下午，或者过了一两天，也许他们甚至还没去，我不记得了。
I don't think she was at the run-through.
我觉得她没参加排练。
I think she got cast later.
我觉得她是后来才被选上的。
So I'm always amazed when actors can come on and just crush it as a guest star.
所以我总是很惊讶，演员们能作为客串明星登场并表现得如此出色。
Because you're really coming in.
因为你真的是刚加入。
I remember someone said, here's what guest starring in law and order is like, it's like, I'm unloading groceries.
我记得有人说过，客串《法律与秩序》是什么感觉，就像是，我在卸杂货。
My wife is dead?
我妻子死了？
Like you just have to pivot from this insane, like, banal task to the most emotional thing.
就像你必须从这种疯狂的、平庸的任务中，瞬间切换到最情绪化的状态。
And the series regulars are just like, that's right, your wife is dead.
而剧中的常驻演员就像是，没错，你妻子死了。
Like they get to be stoic.
他们表现得很冷静。
and kind of, you know, chill, right?
而且，你知道，很淡定，对吧？
Yeah, it's really hard to fly in and do that.
是啊，飞过来做这些真的很难。
And this was a great episode for that, right?
这一集在这方面表现得很棒，对吧？
Those, everybody in this episode was great.
这一集里的每个人都很棒。
And then it needed to be, because everyone's stuck in a fucking limo.
而且必须如此，因为每个人都被困在了一辆该死的豪华轿车里。
I love that it's an episode about New Year's Eve parties, and you don't see one second of a single New Year's Eve party.
我喜欢这一集是关于除夕派对的，但你一秒钟的除夕派对都没看到。
It's very like Rose and Krantz and Guildenstern are dead, like the Hamlet stories happening somewhere else.
这很像《罗森格兰兹和吉尔登斯吞死了》，就像哈姆雷特的故事发生在别处一样。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
Well, also, you know, the thing about New Year's Eve being miserable, like, this is another thing where the what was actually happening in the fictional world was mirroring what was happening in our world.
嗯，还有，你知道，关于除夕夜很痛苦这件事，这又是另一回事，虚构世界里发生的事情反映了我们现实世界中发生的事情。
Like we weren't happy in that limo, like it started to feel incredibly claustrophobic.
就像我们在那辆豪华轿车里并不开心，感觉非常幽闭恐惧。
You needed to get out and stretch your legs and it was just it was just it was just like a pressure.
你需要出去伸展一下双腿，那感觉就像是一种压力。
It must have been hot in there too.
里面一定也很热。
It was lightning in your face and your maybe and I wonder if that's why because I did one okay I have one ding.
灯光直射你的脸，也许……我在想是不是因为这个，因为我有一个小发现。
I like to give notes on the episodes when I watch them now and no one was dressed warmly enough for New Year's Eve in New York.
我现在看剧的时候喜欢做笔记，没人为纽约的除夕夜穿得足够暖和。
It felt a little LA, it felt a little LA, right?
感觉有点像洛杉矶，感觉有点像洛杉矶，对吧？
There was an evidence of big bulky jackets, and then like even what they were wearing, maybe the jackets were all in a corner somewhere of the limo in a pile maybe, but even what they're wearing like Robins in this like sleeveless, like it's like the whole time, like they would be so fucking freezing.
没有看到厚重的大外套，甚至他们穿的衣服，也许外套都堆在豪华轿车的某个角落里，但即使是他们穿的衣服，比如罗宾穿的那种无袖的，就像整个过程，他们会冷得要死。
But I thought part of it is how hot it was in that limo, and wardrobe is like, they're gonna be sweating balls in there if we put them all in sweaters and shit.
但我认为部分原因是那辆豪华轿车里太热了，服装组觉得，如果我们让他们穿毛衣之类的，他们会热得满头大汗。
I'm almost sure we had that conversation, and I'm almost sure that was a consideration.
我几乎确定我们讨论过这个问题，也几乎确定这是一个考虑因素。
Like we, and you don't want to have bulky jackets that you're carrying in and out of the car.
就像我们，你也不想带着笨重的大外套进进出出车子。
I think we just made a game time decision, like we're not gonna, and also the planet, yeah, wasn't as warm as it is now.
我想我们只是临时做了一个决定，我们不打算……而且，地球，是的，当时还没现在这么暖和。
So.
所以。
It would have been cold.
本来会很冷的。
I was watching her throw back on and she was like, no, I call bullshit.
我看着她回放，她说，不，我觉得这是胡扯。
They would be much more mumbled after us again.
他们应该会更畏缩才对。
Do you know what made me laugh, which was something that, I can't remember who was the big champion of this.
你知道什么让我笑了，我不记得是谁最坚持这么做了。
I think Jason was in on this, but we had this the whole nine years.
我觉得杰森也参与了，但我们整整九年都这样。
but when the car stops, we would go like that.
但当车停下来时，我们会那样晃一下。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
And I noticed there was one that I kind of missed.
我注意到有一个我漏掉了。
Like I was like, oh yeah, we're supposed to, but everyone was really into doing it.
就像我当时想，哦对，我们应该那样做，但每个人都很热衷于做这个动作。
But I always thought it was silly because you're not going that fast.
但我一直觉得这很傻，因为车速并不快。
It's New York City, right?
这是纽约市，对吧？
Like you're going 15 miles an hour and you stop.
你以每小时15英里的速度行驶，然后停下来。
You don't burn a bumper driver.
你又不是在追尾。
But everyone was really into doing it.
但每个人都很热衷于做这个。
And it was just like this funny little joke that is not that funny in the episode.
这就像是一个有趣的小笑话，但在剧里其实没那么好笑。
It's just, it was funny on set.
只是，在片场的时候这很有趣。
You know, it's almost getting like getting the general It's trying to get the general.
你知道，这几乎就像是在找那个将军，是在试图找那个将军。
Yeah, it's really right.
是啊，确实如此。
Yeah, that's really funny I love those things that could become runners over nine years just just in your own mind as actors like you You guys are working in guys guys guys a lot for a while because Michael Shai always used to say guys guys guys You're like if there's just the word guys in the script you would always change it to guys guys guys guys To our AD Michael yeah, this is a sentence that I don't think had ever been uttered on on national television before, but I think we were the first to say, hell of a woman, let's go get some hot dogs.
是啊，那真的很有趣，我喜欢那些在九年里能成为我们演员心中“梗”的东西，就像你们，你们有一段时间经常说“伙计们伙计们伙计们”，因为迈克尔·沙伊总是说“伙计们伙计们伙计们”，你们就像是，如果剧本里只要有“伙计们”这个词，你们总会把它改成“伙计们伙计们伙计们伙计们”。对我们的助理导演迈克尔说，是的，我觉得这是一句在全国电视节目中从未出现过的台词，但我认为我们是第一个说出“真是个了不起的女人，我们去吃热狗吧”的人。
Right?
对吧？
It's such a weird turn.
这转折太奇怪了。
Hell of a woman.
真是个了不起的女人。
He says it's very cold hell of a woman.
他说得很冷淡，“真是个了不起的女人”。
You know, in some ways, Marshall's entire personalities encapsulated in that whole line.
你知道，在某种程度上，马歇尔的整个性格都浓缩在那一句台词里了。
So he's got like his romantic kind of like, I love this woman and I'm gonna always be here for her.
所以他既有浪漫的一面，比如“我爱这个女人，我会永远支持她”。
And also, god damn it, let's get those hot dogs.
同时又觉得，“该死，去吃那些热狗吧”。
I love after that moment, the cut to the next scene is him saying, wow, we're riding around in a limo eating hot dogs.
我喜欢那个瞬间之后，切到下一个场景是他说的，“哇，我们坐在豪华轿车里吃热狗”。
It's like we're the president.
就像我们是总统一样。
We're the president.
我们是总统。
But you know what the president does.
但你知道总统会做什么。
That's now what our president does.
那现在就是我们总统会做的事。
That is a 100 percent now, you know, but back then it was kind of absurd.
那百分之百是现在的样子，你知道，但在当时这有点荒谬。
But now literally like our president is in limos with Big Macs.
但现在，我们的总统真的会坐在豪华轿车里吃巨无霸。
He's 100 percent doing that as we speak.
此时此刻他百分之百就在这么做。
old man.
老头子。
He musted me fell in love with you.
他一定爱上你了。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials back to show.
现在是广告时间，广告结束回到节目。
Okay, this is where I got to call out a, uh, this is where I got to call out a, uh, a dated thing.
好吧，这里我得指出一个，呃，这里我得指出一个，呃，过时的东西。
And it made me laugh every time.
而且每次都让我发笑。
Yeah.
是啊。
I can't get through the circuits are jam.
“我打不通，线路占线了。”
What the fuck was happening?
到底发生了什么鬼？
We said that so many times.
我们说了那么多次。
So many times.
说了那么多次。
You picture like the the old time the operator like trying to plug in the things and get the calls through.
你想象一下那种老式的接线员，试图插上插头接通电话的样子。
I was like, are we radar from mash?
我当时想，我们是在演《陆军野战医院》吗？
What's happening?
到底怎么了？
Are they trilikes?
那是三线电话吗？
We're trying to get to Turkey on the line and see if they've got some extra you know what this exchange maybe laughs because Marshall goes, I can't get through the circuits Mr. jammed and you made me say well that's New Year's Eve for you what the fuck was that a note or did we do did where we asked to do I got I dabbed in my skin crawl so much I'm like is it 1874 like what's happening right now uh Tony Express I can't get through the Lily Lily it's Marshall stop and then at the end there's a nice daguerreotype photograph whoosh with the big like yeah that's it's everything about those moments we're so I was sitting there going why did we act like it was I didn't I can't expect it that's it feels like it was a note that we got enough people enough wimium listeners want this I think a funny t-shirt would be I can't get through the circuits or jam circuits or jam it's like three times we've had that phrase I think it's four.
我们是在试图联系土耳其，看看他们有没有多余的……你知道为什么这段对话让我发笑吗？因为马歇尔说“我打不通，线路占线了”，然后你让我说“这就是除夕夜啊”，这到底是什么鬼？这是剧本批注吗？还是我们被要求这么做的？我当时尴尬得起鸡皮疙瘩，我在想，现在是1874年吗？到底发生了什么？呃，托尼快车，我打不通，莉莉，莉莉，马歇尔，停下。最后还有一个那种老式的银版摄影照片，伴随着“嗖”的一声，那种感觉……是的，关于那些时刻的一切，我当时坐在那儿想，为什么我们要表现得好像……我无法理解，这感觉像是我们收到的一个批注，觉得会有足够多的听众想要这个。我觉得一件有趣的T恤上可以印“我打不通，线路占线了，线路占线了”，我想我们说了这个短语三次，我觉得是四次。
I think it's four.
我觉得是四次。
That's four.
那是四次。
I mean, it really is a runner in the thing.
我的意思是，它确实成了剧中的一个梗。
And it really, it makes us look like we were, yeah, like, mash.
而且它确实让我们看起来像是在演……是的，像《陆军野战医院》。
Like it makes you look.
它让你看起来。
It's a hundred years ago.
就像是一百年前。
And it's like, were we so concerned that people would be like, ah, why can't they get some in a cell phone?
而且就像是，我们当时是不是太担心观众会问“啊，为什么他们不用手机打？”
Sometimes you don't hear your ringer.
有时候你听不到铃声。
The call didn't go through.
电话没打通。
That happens now in 2025.
这在2025年的现在也会发生。
There was no need to explain that at any moment.
根本没必要在任何时候解释这一点。
And we were like, really over explaining that one.
而我们当时真的过度解释了这一点。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Oh, God.
Sorry.
抱歉。
Sorry, everyone.
抱歉，各位。
That was a mess on our part.
那是我们搞砸了。
Can I ask if there was mix of broken logic with Marshall's phone?
我能问一下马歇尔的手机是不是出现了逻辑混乱吗？
Yeah, I think there was, because I think she did.
是的，我想是的，因为我觉得她确实那样做了。
I think one of those, like, the circuits are, like, I think one of those, his phone was still stuck in the limo, right?
我想其中一个，比如，线路，我想其中一个，他的手机当时还留在豪华轿车里，对吧？
And she's, and she's still saying that stupid line when that, we didn't have to say it there.
而且她还在说那句愚蠢的台词，当时我们根本没必要在那儿说那句话。
Because anyway, I'm sorry, everyone.
总之，抱歉，各位。
No, no.
不，不。
I mean, these are the kind of funny things that it's almost like, you know, like famous when props get misplaced, shot to shot, like famous.
我的意思是，这些都是那种有趣的细节，就像电影里道具在不同镜头间放错位置一样，非常出名。
in great movies, right?
在伟大的电影里，对吧？
Oh, yeah, it happens in everything.
哦，是的，什么电影里都会发生。
It happens in everything you can't avoid it.
这在任何作品里都会发生，你无法避免。
I think in this one too, I think Mo, not Moby, leaves with the disc, believes with like the case of the get-ciked mix, not just the CD itself, but then all of a sudden it's back in the limo.
我想这一集里也是，莫比，不是莫比，他带着光盘离开，带着那个混音带的盒子，不仅仅是CD本身，但突然间它又回到了豪华轿车里。
Empty has pretty city-staking the disc.
Empty（莫比）当时正拿着光盘。
I think that was a glitch.
我觉得那是个失误。
I think I remember getting called out on that and being like, yeah, that feels like weird.
我记得有人指出了这一点，当时我就觉得，是的，这确实很奇怪。
You know, when I was editing one of my movies, I worked with this great editor both times, Michael Miller, and he had edited Raising Arizona and Ghost World and all these really incredible, yeah.
你知道，我在剪辑我的一部电影时，曾两次与一位出色的剪辑师迈克尔·米勒合作，他剪辑过《抚养亚利桑那》和《幽灵世界》以及所有这些非常棒的作品，是的。
Talk about editing.
说到剪辑。
Yeah.
是的。
And he did a couple of Conrad, but he was a great editor.
他剪辑过几部康拉德的电影，他是一位伟大的剪辑师。
I learned a lot from him.
我从他身上学到了很多。
And we had lost a scene, we had edited out a scene, and then it made it look like they changed clothes in the middle of the day.
我们当时丢了一场戏，剪掉了一场戏，结果看起来就像他们在大白天换了衣服一样。
And he said to me, I'll never forget this, he said, audiences don't pay attention to that.
他对我说了这句话，我永远不会忘记，他说，观众根本不会注意这些。
And do you know the Robert Redford movie, Three Days in the Condor?
你知道罗伯特·雷德福的电影《秃鹰三天》吗？
Yeah.
知道。
Originally, the original script was called Six Days in the Condor.
最初，原剧本叫《秃鹰六天》。
And in editing, they were like, we need to compress the time.
在剪辑时，他们觉得需要压缩时间。
It works better as three days.
改成三天效果更好。
And if you watch the movie in the middle of the day, they just switch.
如果你看那部电影，在白天中间，他们就直接切换了。
They're just changing clothes.
他们只是换了衣服。
And he said, no one has ever brought it up in movie history.
他说，电影史上从来没有人提过这一点。
Like no one says anything about it, which I think is an incredible thing.
就像没人会对此说什么一样，我觉得这太不可思议了。
Like, what are we, what are we watching and what are we paying attention to?
就像，我们到底在看什么，我们在关注什么？
You know, but I think I think some of these things like I think there's a timeless aspect to how I made your mother That is why it's so widely beloved because teenagers right now are watching it and it feels relevant to them They can relate to it's not too.
你知道，但我认为《老爸老妈浪漫史》的制作方式有一种永恒感，这就是它如此广受欢迎的原因，因为现在的青少年也在看它，而且觉得它很有共鸣，他们能感同身受，它并没有太……
It's not so far like It's been swallowed by the past But there are these markers that it was 2005 and I think that they're sweet and cool and not to be apologized for actually No, no.
它并没有太遥远，就像它被过去吞没了一样，但这些标志表明那是2005年，我认为这些都很可爱、很酷，其实根本不需要道歉。不，不。
It captures it.
它捕捉到了那个时代。
And look, it's a story being told from 2030 about 2005.
而且你看，这是一个从2030年讲述2005年故事的故事。
And in 2030, you'd be looking back at it saying what we're saying right now.
到了2030年，你回头看它时，会说出我们现在说的话。
We're in 2025 right now.
我们现在是在2025年。
Yeah, you almost like created a context where you get away with all that.
是的，你几乎创造了一个让你能摆脱所有这些问题的语境。
It's okay to say the year.
说出年份是可以的。
It's okay because it's a story about that year.
没关系，因为它就是一个关于那一年的故事。
What will be weird is when the real world passes 2030 if we all survive that long.
如果现实世界过了2030年，如果我们都能活那么久的话，那才会变得奇怪。
Who knows?
谁知道呢？
TBD.
待定。
And that is going to be like, oh shit, that's adding another level of weirdness.
那会像，哦该死，这又增加了一层怪异感。
But at the moment, it's still, Yeah, it's okay this that happened in that year of Ted Mosby's life.
但目前为止，是的，发生在泰德·莫斯比生命中的那一年是没问题的。
Yeah, future Ted gets to talk about it Yeah, he's not gonna upgrade anyone's phones in the story.
是的，未来的泰德可以谈论它，是的，他不会在故事里升级任何人的手机。
Yeah Although I don't think anyone was saying the phrase the circuits are busy even in two that I don't remember ever saying that Well, that's New Year's Eve for you That line jumped out at me to Josh and I was like poor Josh having to say that line Well, you'll notice that I really try to make sure work of it.
是的，虽然我不认为当时有人会说“线路繁忙”这句台词，我不记得我曾经说过那句话。好吧，这就是除夕夜的你。那句台词对我来说很突兀，乔什，我当时想，可怜的乔什不得不说那句台词。好吧，你会注意到我真的很努力地确保把它处理好。
I was like well, that's what you do when you get a real clunker Yeah, you just try to act like it's you just throw it away, you know, I'm gonna look for more of those as we continue the rewatch I think if it was like the third or fourth season, I would have gone up to you and said I'm not saying this line You should have you and you damn well should have I know I was still trying to be a good student, you know I'm still trying to get the a I Why I thought you sit when mo when not Moby says I thought you said Tony and And then he says, so your name is Tony and he says, no, no, it's so funny.
我当时想，好吧，遇到这种烂台词就只能这样了，你只能装作若无其事，直接把它抛在脑后。随着重温的继续，我打算多留意一下这种时刻。我想如果是在第三或第四季，我肯定会走过去对你说：“我不说这句台词。”你当时就该这么做，你绝对应该这么做。我知道，我当时还想做一个好学生，你知道的，我还在努力争取拿A。为什么我以为你说的是……当Moby说……我以为你说的是Tony，然后他说：“所以你叫Tony？”他说：“不，不，这太搞笑了。”
He is so crazy and and we and he's wonderful that in that episode.
他太疯狂了，而且他在那一集里的表现真是太棒了。
And then what I love about that moment is you figure, well, that's it.
关于那一刻，我最喜欢的是你以为，好吧，就这样了。
We're never going to hear know this guy's name.
我们永远也不会知道这家伙的名字了。
And then there's that wonderful way later in the episode, Marshall says Moby signs my shirt.
然后在那一集快结束时，有一个很棒的桥段，Marshall说Moby在我的衬衫上签名了。
He tries to run it says Eric on the top of the shirt.
他试着跑过去，衬衫上面写着Eric。
We did get to solve that mystery is the guy's name is Eric, which as you put it out Josh sounds not at all like Tony or Moby or Moby and also like just Eric it's just like really crudely drawn like it's not like a signature it's just like the guy's a proper psycho.
我们确实解开了这个谜团，这家伙的名字叫Eric，正如你指出的Josh，听起来一点也不像Tony或Moby，而且那个名字写得非常潦草，根本不像签名，这家伙简直是个彻头彻尾的疯子。
He's a psycho he's waving that gun around he did JP Manuke captured that unhinged energy very well.
他是个疯子，挥舞着那把枪，JP Manoux把那种精神失常的状态演得非常好。
Speaking of waving the gun around I did catch something I did that I thought was delightful.
说到挥舞枪，我确实捕捉到了一个我觉得很有趣的细节。
When he's waving the gun around I hold the party schedule note card up to my head to protect me from an errant bullet.
当他挥舞枪的时候，我把派对日程表的卡片举到头顶，以防流弹。
If you look, I'm holding it up like, oh, God.
如果你仔细看，我把它举起来的样子，就像是“天哪”。
There's a metaphor there, because Ted thinks plans will save him.
这其中有个隐喻，因为Ted认为计划能拯救他。
Plans will save everything.
计划能解决一切。
Exactly.
没错。
确实。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
So, yeah, I think it's the most we've ever played one song in the Bunch of the Song.
所以，是的，我想这是我们在一集里播放同一首歌次数最多的一次。
I know there's probably no other episode where a song starts and stops a dozen times.
我知道可能没有哪一集会像这样，一首歌断断续续响了十几次。
And very, I will call one other cool song out there.
另外，我还要提另一首很酷的歌。
the song major leagues by pavement plays for also in a major leagues, or maybe it's just major league singular, a great song from Terry Twilight by pavement that is about being ready for great things.
Pavement乐队的《Major Leagues》也在那一集里播放，或者歌名可能是单数的《Major League》，这是Pavement乐队《Terror Twilight》专辑里的一首好歌，讲的是为伟大的事情做好准备。
It is a great like love song that sort of talks about I'm going to screw up and I'm ready like bring on the major leagues, like bring on a real love now.
这是一首很棒的情歌，大概是在说“我会搞砸，但我准备好了”，就像是“迎接大联盟吧”，迎接一段真正的爱情吧。
And that's near the end, near the end that great ending where Ted walks off kind of into the future.
那是在结尾附近，那个很棒的结尾，Ted走向未来。
But it's sort of great because you think that's the ending song, but then it gets cut off by Robin's billionaire, hundred-millionaire boyfriend showing up and he kind of cuts off that song.
但这很棒，因为你以为那是片尾曲，结果被Robin那个亿万富翁男友的出现给打断了，他切断了那首歌。
I like the kind of fake out where you think that song is kind of going to carry you through to the happy ending.
我喜欢那种假象，你以为那首歌会一直伴随你走向幸福的结局。
And it doesn't.
但并没有。
It gets cut off and Ted has a bit of very bittersweet in years Eve with this little moment of hope from Robin.
它被切断了，Ted在跨年夜经历了一段苦乐参半的时刻，带着Robin给的一点点希望。
But that was a little fake out ending song of pavement that didn't actually be the ending song.
但那是一首假装是片尾曲的Pavement的歌，实际上并不是真正的片尾曲。
I like that.
我喜欢那样。
I did.
我也是。
We talked about this, but I love the sunroof being this other playing space and I just There was something so pleasurable.
我们讨论过这个，但我喜欢天窗作为另一个表演空间，而且……那种感觉太美妙了。
Maybe it was just, I got to leave the limo, but there was something so nice about popping up and having a scene up there.
也许只是因为我终于能离开豪华轿车了，但能探出头去演一场戏，感觉真的很棒。
And also we had talked about this when Mary Beth says she can tell Robins into him and he says, wait, really?
还有，我们之前讨论过，当Mary Beth说她看得出Robin对他有意思，而他说：“等等，真的吗？”
And it occurred to me, like, Ted is a bad actor.
我突然意识到，Ted是个糟糕的演员。
Like I hope I'm a good actor, but Ted is a bad actor.
我希望我是一个好演员，但Ted确实是个糟糕的演员。
It's true.
没错。
He's not a master of disguise.
他不是伪装大师。
Like Barney's a pretty good actor, and most of his life is somewhat of an act or a lot of it.
Barney是个相当不错的演员，他大部分生活都在演戏，或者说很大程度上是这样。
Yes.
是的。
But Ted is just, he's a guile-less, is that the word?
但Ted只是……他很单纯，是这个词吗？
Like he's...
就像他……
He's guile-less.
他很单纯。
Yeah.
是的。
没错。
There's no, there's no smoke screen.
没有烟雾弹。
There's nothing, he's not masking.
什么都没有，他没有掩饰。
He can't help himself but ask his date if she really thinks Robin likes him.
他忍不住要问他的约会对象，她是否真的觉得Robin喜欢他。
It's that there's something so, it's sort of shitty and great at the same time because Ted just can't lie.
这有点……既糟糕又伟大，因为Ted就是不会撒谎。
He can't cover that up.
他无法掩饰这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
没错。
that moment.
那一刻。
Great.
太棒了。
Speaking of smoke screens, I love Marshall emerging from that steam.
说到烟雾弹，我喜欢马歇尔从蒸汽中现身的那一幕。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Lily, I'm going to go call Marshall and she just means calling his name out.
莉莉说“我要去叫马歇尔”，她其实只是喊了他的名字。
That was I love when we have those little magic New York moments and that entire city he can she can call his name echoing through the buildings through the canyons of New York and he will come running out of the smoke that I love the metaphysical weirdness of New York is a very strange place.
我喜欢我们拥有那些纽约式的小小魔幻时刻，在整座城市里，她喊他的名字，声音在建筑间回荡，穿过纽约的峡谷，他就会从烟雾中跑出来，我喜欢纽约那种形而上的怪诞感，那是个非常奇特的地方。
It's this intensely small village and it's one of the biggest cities in the world.
它既是一个极其狭小的村庄，又是世界上最宏大的城市之一。
all at the same time.
同时兼具。
Oh, at the same time.
哦，同时兼具。
Yeah.
是的。
And there's something like, if you really understand New York and the geography of at least Manhattan, that's impossible.
而且，如果你真的了解纽约，至少是曼哈顿的地理环境，那是不可能的。
It's impossible.
那是不可能的。
It's like, it's too loud.
太吵了。
It's too crazy.
太疯狂了。
Like, even if he was half a block away, you can't hear someone screaming a flag away.
即使他就在半个街区外，你也不可能听到有人在隔着一条街大喊。
I knew you.
我了解你。
In New York City.
在纽约市。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's magic.
但这就是魔力。
Like, Alec and I talk about this, like, like, just adding magic into scripts.
就像亚历克和我谈论的那样，在剧本里加入魔力。
Like Alec, I've been to tell something you told me about Fargo speaking of the Coen brothers.
亚历克，我得说说你告诉过我关于《冰血暴》的事，说到科恩兄弟。
You said a female police chief investigating a murder in, where was it, Minnesota, is great, but that she's pregnant is magic, right?
你说一位女警察局长在明尼苏达州调查谋杀案很棒，但她怀孕了就是魔力，对吧？
Right.
没错。
Yeah.
是的。
loving emerging from.
从……中现身。
I mean, it's almost like a professional wrestler coming out of the dressing room, like in the fog.
我的意思是，这就像职业摔跤手从更衣室走出来，带着烟雾一样。
Like he, there was something he, you could tell he was in the same way, like, okay, awesome.
你可以看出他当时的状态，就像是，好吧，太棒了。
He loved the dance.
他喜欢这种表演。
Like, he loved coming out of that.
他喜欢那样出场。
Yeah.
是的。
Now he runs, he appears out of the smoke.
现在他跑过来，从烟雾中现身。
The Bon Jovi song for the first time becomes full score.
邦乔维的歌第一次变成了完整的配乐。
It's not being played in the limo.
它不再是在豪华轿车里播放的背景音。
It's actually the score and it plays him in.
它实际上成了配乐，伴随着他出场。
And it is a very get psyched moment.
那是一个非常让人热血沸腾的时刻。
And Jason leaned into it.
杰森完全沉浸其中。
I love, I love that moment so much.
我太喜欢那一刻了。
And there's a third is magic like the fact that not Moby is at the same party.
还有第三种魔力，比如“非莫比”也在同一个派对上这件事。
They were gonna go to right the billion the mill hundred Millionaire finding Robin at all marshals names somehow magically calling him out of the mist His wife calling his name sort of makes him appear I feel like he was way far away from them and a portal appeared And you ran through the portal towards Lily's voice and he jumped down three floors Yeah, he jumped three floors, but Lily's voice made it all possible.
他们当时正要去找那个亿万富翁，结果马修的名字不知怎么就像魔法一样从迷雾中被呼唤了出来，他妻子喊他的名字仿佛让他现了身，我觉得他当时离他们很远，然后出现了一个传送门，他朝着莉莉的声音跑进传送门，跳下了三层楼，没错，他跳了三层楼，但莉莉的声音让这一切成为了可能。
He loves her so much.
他太爱她了。
I love that moment so much much.
我太喜欢那个瞬间了。
What's wonderful about this shows use of that kind of magic is that it's almost leaning on the fact that you have purchased a kind of trust from your audience to then allow to break all the rules that you have.
这部剧运用这种魔法最妙的地方在于，它几乎是建立在观众对剧集的信任之上，从而允许自己打破所有既定规则。
Because certainly if you mess up continuity somewhere and you're wearing the wrong clothing, you're wearing the wrong guy, that's like a ding for an audience.
因为如果你在某个地方搞砸了连续性，穿错了衣服，或者找错了人，那对观众来说就像是一个败笔。
They'll sort of notice that if all of a sudden you just break reality and just say is that what you're saying is, do you want to have fun or not?
如果突然打破现实，观众会注意到，你是在说，你想不想玩得开心点？
Right.
没错。
And I think that once you've got them, they love these people and they know what the show is.
我觉得一旦你抓住了观众，他们爱上了这些角色，他们就了解这部剧的调性。
Oh, it's not a show that's supernatural.
哦，这不是一部超自然剧。
This is a real life show, I'm in.
这是一部现实生活剧，我深陷其中。
But now you're asking, hey, do you want to something crazy with me?
但现在你问，嘿，你想跟我一起做点疯狂的事吗？
Come jump out a window with me and land three floors down and you had them at that point.
跟我一起跳出窗外，降落到三层楼下，在那一刻你就已经征服他们了。
And so you could introduce this kind of thing.
所以你可以引入这种情节。
trust the audience to make these magical realism-based leaps, except in the case of not being able to complete a cell phone call, in which case we have to say the circuit service.
信任观众会接受这些基于魔幻现实主义的跳跃，除了无法完成手机通话的情况，那种情况下我们必须解释是信号问题。
That one we had to explain.
那个我们必须解释。
Marshall appearing out of the smoke, that's fine.
马修从烟雾中出现，那没问题。
Well, how we may, because it's this memory play, you're allowed to bend time and space and defy the laws of physics in a different way.
嗯，怎么说呢，因为这是一场记忆戏，你可以以不同的方式扭曲时间和空间，违背物理定律。
What a trick.
真是个妙招。
What a magic trick to get to use, is the trick of the unreliable narrator, the unreliability of memory itself.
利用不可靠叙述者和记忆本身不可靠性的技巧，真是一个绝妙的魔术。
This is another magic moment, is that Marshall steals back the CD from Not Moby.
这是另一个神奇的时刻，马修从“假莫比”手中偷回了CD。
Like one, how would he know?
比如，他怎么会知道？
Like the amount of leaps that Marshall would have to make to figure out that this is Barney CD, Not Moby stole it.
马修要做出多少推断才能弄清楚这是巴尼的CD，是被“假莫比”偷走的。
How did you see that?
你是怎么看出来的？
But he thinks he's still Moby.
但他以为他还是莫比。
He's still thinks he's Moby.
他还是以为他是莫比。
But he steals it back.
但他把它偷了回来。
And it made me feel, because we get it, I don't remember when telepathy appeared, but it's one of my favorite how I made your mother jokes, is that they could speak telepathically to each other?
这让我很有感触，因为我们懂的，我不记得心灵感应是什么时候出现的，但这是我最喜欢的《老爸老妈浪漫史》笑话之一，他们能用心灵感应交流？
Yes, they speak telepathically.
是的，他们用心灵感应交流。
But it made me realize that like, they actually already have telepathy.
但这让我意识到，他们其实已经拥有心灵感应了。
Yes.
是的。
Like they know what they need, they anticipate each other's needs, they can spit, they're sensing something about each other.
他们知道对方需要什么，他们预判对方的需求，他们能心领神会，他们能感知到对方。
They're an ecosystem or a biosphere, you know?
他们是一个生态系统或生物圈，你懂吗？
It's even better that he thought it was really Moby.
更棒的是他以为那真的是莫比。
He's like, I'm stealing that thing back from Moby.
他心想，我要从莫比那里把那东西偷回来。
Moby cannot steal.
莫比不能偷东西。
Moby may think he's a big, famous star, but he cannot steal my friends and get psychics.
莫比可能以为自己是个大明星，但他不能偷我朋友的东西。
And Barney is like suddenly whole again when he gets that back.
当巴尼拿回CD时，他仿佛又完整了。
It's, yeah, I really loved rewatching this one.
是啊，重温这一集我真的很喜欢。
I really, this is a fun one.
这一集真的很有趣。
We didn't do a Christmas episode in season one.
我们在第一季没有拍圣诞特辑。
I can't quite tell you why.
我不太能说出原因。
Maybe it had to do with air dates.
也许和播出日期有关。
Maybe we just didn't have a good idea for it.
也许只是我们没想出什么好点子。
We had a good idea for Thanksgiving episode and a good idea for a New Year's episode and a good idea for a Halloween episode, but we skipped Christmas.
我们有感恩节特辑的好点子，有新年特辑的好点子，还有万圣节特辑的好点子，但我们跳过了圣诞节。
I'm so glad we did a New Year's one.
我很高兴我们拍了新年特辑。
What I loved about the comment to begin this episode, I forget her name, forgive me, I like to remember her person's name at the beginning, Andrea, from Remind me of everything about Andrea from Mexico.
我喜欢这集开头的那条评论，我忘了她的名字，请原谅，我喜欢记住开头那位观众的名字，安德烈亚，来自墨西哥的安德烈亚，提醒我关于她的一切。
Andrea from Mexico, I know, I just wanted to share what I was gonna write.
来自墨西哥的安德烈亚，我知道，我只是想分享一下我要写的内容。
What I loved about her comment was that she says, she watches it every year right after midnight.
我喜欢她的评论是因为她说，她每年午夜过后都会看这一集。
I love that that's part of her tradition, you know what I mean?
我喜欢这成为她传统的一部分，你明白我的意思吗？
That's what she hits play on that, just like starting up the Punjabi song.
就像播放旁遮普歌曲一样，她会准时按下播放键。
So thank you, Andrea, sorry, I forgot your name briefly.
谢谢你，安德烈，抱歉，我刚才一时忘了你的名字。
For Mexico, your comment was amazing.
关于墨西哥，你的评论太棒了。
I love that it's part of your New Year's tradition.
我很喜欢这成为你新年传统的一部分。
We didn't do too many New Year's episodes, but this one, this one was a good one.
我们没做过太多新年特辑，但这一集，这一集真的很不错。
I feel like we're actually up to the point plot-wise where Derek comes back and Ted is crushed.
我觉得我们在剧情上已经进展到德里克回来、泰德心碎的时刻了。
And I will say, I don't know, there was something, I really believed Ted's devastation when Derek hops in that limo.
我得说，我不知道，当时有一种感觉，当德里克跳进那辆豪华轿车时，我真的相信了泰德的绝望。
Like there was something about my face that I was like, that was good film acting, Radner.
就好像我的表情里有一种东西，让我觉得，演得真好，拉德纳。
I'll see, I like hearing you say that.
我会看的，我喜欢听你这么说。
I like hearing you admit that you've been good on this TV show.
我喜欢听你承认你在剧里演得很好。
I felt like, I really felt for him.
我当时的感觉是，我真的为他感到难过。
I was like, oh, this is such a bummer for him.
我当时想，噢，这对他来说真是太扫兴了。
And the night was going particularly well, you know, for him, vis-a-vis Robin up until that point.
而且那天晚上对他来说特别顺利，你知道的，在那之前他和罗宾的关系进展得不错。
But I think he says the line, or maybe the narrator says all night long, I've been trying to chase something down that was right there in that limo.
但我记得他说过那句台词，或者可能是旁白说的，整晚我都在追逐某些东西，而它其实就在那辆车里。
Does he say that?
他是这么说的吗？
Yeah, it says.
是的，是这么说的。
And it made me think about, you know, you really watch these people from their mid to late 20s to their early to mid 30s.
这让我想到，你知道，你真的看着这些人从二十五六岁一直到三十出头。
That's kind of the arc.
这就是整个弧线。
And it's a really pivotal time, that decade, 25 to 35, let's call it, is huge, right?
这是一个非常关键的时期，那十年，我们称之为25到35岁，非常重要，对吧？
And there's a huge transition.
而且有一个巨大的转变。
And I think your 20s are really about chasing experiences.
我觉得二十多岁的时候，真的就是在追逐各种经历。
That's why it's like, we have five parties to hit.
这就是为什么我们会说，我们要赶五个派对。
We're going out, we're gonna like go West, young man.
我们要出去，我们要像年轻人一样去闯荡。
Like we're seeking our fortune, we're seeking romance, seeking connection, you know, all of it, and it's out there, right?
我们是在寻求财富，寻求浪漫，寻求联系，你知道，所有这些，而且它们都在外面，对吧？
Everything is outside of you.
一切都在你之外。
But then maturity, I wrote this down, is realizing it's about what's inside you and what's in right in front of you, right?
但后来成熟了，我写下了这一点，就是意识到这一切关乎你内心深处的东西，以及就在你眼前的东西，对吧？
Like it's like there's not a better life lurking out there.
就像并不是外面潜伏着更好的生活。
It's like the universe is inside me and also the people I love are in front of me and it's best to be present with those people.
宇宙就在我心中，而且我爱的人就在我面前，最好是和这些人在一起。
So I think that in some ways that's the moral of the episode, which is like, and Ted changes, Ted learns that in that episode because he's driving them all over the city and he says, no, the best party is right here.
所以我认为在某种程度上这就是这一集的寓意，泰德在那一集里改变了，他学到了这一点，因为他载着他们在城市里到处转，然后他说，不，最好的派对就在这里。
I loved Ted in that moment when he said that.
我爱死那一刻的泰德了。
This is as clear an illustration of it's about the journey, not the destination because they literally never get to their destination.
这完美诠释了“重在过程，而非终点”，因为他们实际上从未到达目的地。
You never get out of the limo.
他们从未下过那辆豪华轿车。
It's all journey.
全程都是过程。
Yeah, it's all journey, but not the journey song.
是的，全程都是过程，但不是Journey乐队的那首歌。
Except for the not that song.
除了那首歌以外。
Sorry for the Lord.
抱歉，Lord。
Yeah.
是的。
And to be fair, it also would have worked great.
平心而论，那首歌其实效果也会很好。
To be fair.
平心而论。
No, no, I could, I could, you could make a case for that.
不，不，我可以，我可以，你可以为那个选择辩护。
But there's something.
但确实有某种东西。
Totally.
完全同意。
Because the shot through the heart really just works every time.
因为那句“射穿心脏”确实每次都很有效果。
It just pops so hard.
它太抓人了。
It comes in at a million.
它来得太猛了。
I will say that I thought the last scene with me and Kobe was pretty perfect.
我得说，我觉得我和科比的最后一场戏非常完美。
Perfect.
完美。
The writing of it was perfect.
剧本写得太完美了。
There was no fat on it.
没有任何多余的废话。
it's just so simple and you have enough history fueling them at this point eleven episodes in where not much needs to be said it's like it's this you know and you could almost plausibly make the case let's say Ted thought it was a bigger deal than she did you could almost make the case like you could interpret that as romantic or not like it was actually we threaded an interesting needle there yeah it was enigmatic there was something charged to it it was there I love that moment.
它非常简单，而且在这一集，也就是第十一集，你们之间已经有了足够的历史积淀，不需要说太多，就是这样，你知道，你几乎可以合理地辩称，泰德觉得这比她觉得的更重要，你几乎可以将其解读为浪漫或非浪漫，我们实际上在那里处理得非常微妙，是的，它很神秘，有一种张力，它就在那里，我爱那一刻。
It tees up the entire rest of season one in the best possible way.
它以最好的方式为第一季的剩余部分做了铺垫。
Pineapple kind of brought it back, sort of got those embers going again a little bit with Ted's recalling her and bringing this back up at him and a little bit on the back burner, the Robin thing for a while.
“菠萝”事件算是把这事儿又带回来了，泰德提起这件事，让罗宾的事儿重新回到了大家的视线里，之前这事儿算是被搁置了一段时间。
And this is bringing it back forward and this launches.
现在这事儿又被提上日程，故事也由此展开。
I would argue this is a really good midway point of a season episode because it really launches the second half.
我认为这集作为季中集非常出色，因为它真正开启了下半季的剧情。
Yeah, yeah.
没错，没错。
It also made me feel like when I was watching Ted, really through the first 11 episodes, Like, I think there's a pattern, I don't know if this is like a, if there's a term for this, but I hear from a lot of people who say, oh, I was very dear friends with my husband.
这还让我想到，我在看泰德前11集的时候，我觉得这似乎有个规律，我不知道这有没有专门的术语，但我听很多人说，哦，我和我丈夫以前是非常亲密的朋友。
He was just in my friend group, but I never thought of him that way.
他就在我的朋友圈里，但我从来没往那方面想过。
And then you kind of like, you know, when the lights come up at the end of whatever, your age, you go, oh, this is the person I like the most and feel the most comfortable around.
然后当你到了某个年纪，灯光亮起时，你会突然意识到，哦，原来这就是我最喜欢、相处起来最舒服的人。
I feel like Ted's kind of like the prototype for the guy, like in your friend group that a woman eventually realizes is like the best and kindest guy and falls for him.
我觉得泰德就像是那种男生的原型，就是那种在你的朋友圈里，女生最终意识到他是最好、最善良的人，然后爱上他。
But he's easy to overlook when you're on that experience hunt, you know?
但在你追求那种刺激体验的时候，他很容易被忽视，你懂吗？
You kind of don't see that guy.
你往往看不见那个人。
And I think that's what he said in his first monologue, like that monologue in the pilot.
我觉得他在试播集里的那段独白就是这个意思。
Like, I'm not good at this stuff, but I'd be a really good husband.
他说，我不擅长这些，但我会是个很好的丈夫。
Yeah, yeah.
没错，没错。
Once you realize it's not about getting the five parties, the party's right here.
一旦你意识到重点不在于去参加那五个派对，而是派对就在这里。
Oh my God.
天哪。
This is it, the party is here, you know?
就是这样，派对就在这里，你懂吗？
And I think like they get so excited like when Marshall comes back or Lily gets back, because it's like it doesn't feel right unless they're all together.
我觉得他们之所以那么兴奋，是因为马修回来了，或者莉莉回来了，因为如果他们不聚在一起，感觉就不对劲。
And in some ways, this episode more than any other episode is the five of them are a gang, like they're an absolute gang and Robin has been fully folded in.
在某种程度上，这一集比其他任何一集都更能体现他们五个人是一个整体，他们绝对是一个铁三角，而且罗宾已经完全融入其中了。
So yeah, I was actually, I was pretty delighted by this episode.
所以，是的，我其实对这一集感到非常高兴。
I remember loving the script and it being a hard shoot, but I think it endures, like I think it was worth it.
我记得我很喜欢这个剧本，虽然拍摄过程很艰难，但我认为它经得起时间的考验，我觉得这一切都是值得的。
We thought we were giving everyone the simplest shoot of the year, and everyone was cursing our names by the end of the week, but it was a good one.
我们本以为这会是全年最轻松的一场戏，结果到周末结束时，每个人都在咒骂我们，但这一集确实很棒。
So we're up to our very special section, which I think I'm gonna amend this, Alec, but I'm just now going to call this Questions and Observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother, and also happens to be married to Josh.
现在到了我们的特别环节，我想修改一下，亚历克，我打算把它改名为“从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》的临床心理学家（同时也是乔什的妻子）提出的问题与观察”。
I just cut out relationship expert, because I don't know, I don't know that she would describe herself that way, and I don't know that anyone could describe themselves that way.
我删掉了“关系专家”这个头衔，因为我不知道她是否会这样描述自己，我也不确定有人能这样描述自己。
way.
方式。
You know what I mean?
你明白我的意思吗？
I'd be wary of a relationship expert, except Terry Reel, who's a very interesting psychologist, if you've ever listened to him.
我会对“关系专家”保持警惕，除了特里·里尔，他是一位非常有趣的心理学家，如果你听过他的话。
But he's very smart about relationships.
但他对人际关系确实很有见地。
All right, we will amend it.
好吧，我们会修改的。
We will have amended it in our graphic as you are.
我们会在图表里把它改掉，就像你要求的那样。
If you're watching this on YouTube, you removed and here she is the not relationship expert.
如果你正在YouTube上观看，你已经删掉了，现在她就是那位“非关系专家”。
This episode almost felt like a microcosm of a macro theme of the series, which I think is summed up by what Ted said at the very end of the episode, and I wrote it down.
这一集感觉就像是整部剧宏大主题的一个缩影，我认为泰德在剧集结尾说的话总结得很好，我把它记下来了。
So he said, you probably want to feel bad for your old man at this point in the story.
他说，在这个故事的这个节点，你可能想为你的老爸感到难过。
Well, don't.
好吧，别难过。
Not every night has a happy ending, but all of it's important, all of it's leading somewhere.
并不是每个夜晚都有圆满的结局，但这一切都很重要，这一切都在引领你走向某个地方。
And for sitcom, this is truly a metaphysical spiritual lesson.
对于一部情景喜剧来说，这真的是一堂形而上的精神课。
we make plans, the unexpected happens.
我们制定计划，但意外总会发生。
We have a small degree of control and then there's a massive amount that's beyond our control.
我们只有一点点控制权，而剩下的绝大部分都在我们的控制之外。
In this case, the traffic, Lily's feet hurting, Marshall forgetting his phone, not Moby, waving around a gun in the limo.
比如这次，交通堵塞、莉莉脚疼、马修忘了带手机，还有那个不是莫比的人在豪华轿车里挥舞着枪。
But the message of the episode that I took home was to have faith that whatever happens, even if it seems absolutely awful at the time.
但我从这一集中领悟到的信息是，要相信无论发生什么，即使当时看起来糟透了。
It is indeed all important.
这一切确实都很重要。
It's all leading you somewhere, and that somewhere is where you belong.
这一切都在引领你走向某个地方，而那个地方就是你的归宿。
And for Ted, the planner whose plans were undone, it still ultimately led to that moment that we were waiting for, that kiss with Robin.
对于泰德这个计划落空的规划者来说，它最终还是引领他走向了我们期待已久的那个时刻，也就是和罗宾的那一吻。
And though this is only Episode 11, and I have just shy of 200 more to go, my best guess is the entire show is going on fold following the spiritual lesson in a very similar way.
虽然这只是第11集，我还有将近200集要看，但我敢肯定，整部剧的发展都会遵循这个精神课程，以非常相似的方式展开。
Wow, that's uh, but that's too good.
哇，这……这太棒了。
That's better than anything we've said so far.
这比我们目前说的任何话都要好。
Could we just, Alex, reset it down to that one?
亚历克，我们能只保留这一段吗？
It's just gonna be Andrea and Jordana.
以后就只剩下安德里亚和乔丹娜了。
Yeah, I think that's a good cut.
是的，我觉得这个剪辑很棒。
Cut out, everybody, cut out all the dudes.
把大家都剪掉，把所有的男人们都剪掉。
That's such a great comment.
这评论真是太棒了。
I love that she singled out that ending narration, and I love that idea of it's all important, which is different than saying it's all gonna work out.
我很喜欢她特别指出的那段结尾旁白，也很喜欢“一切都很重要”这个观点，这与“一切都会好起来的”说法是不同的。
I'm happy with that wording and that narration, it's true.
我很满意那种措辞和旁白，那是事实。
It's all, it's important.
一切，一切都很重要。
It's not all good.
并非一切都是好的。
It's not all bad.
也并非一切都是坏的。
It's important.
它很重要。
It's important because it's part of your story and it's the accumulation of those sort of story beats of your own life that lead you where you need to be or where you want to be or where you hope to be or where you never thought you would be.
它之所以重要，是因为它是你人生故事的一部分，正是你生命中那些故事节点的积累，把你带到了你需要去的地方，或者你想去的地方，或者你希望去的地方，又或者是你从未想过自己会去的地方。
But then you're happy there.
但最终你在那里感到幸福。
You know, it reminded me of something I'd read that said, like, never trust a memoir or a biography that doesn't have like some scandal in it or the protagonist doesn't look bad.
你知道，这让我想起读过的一句话，大意是：永远不要相信那些没有丑闻，或者主角看起来并不糟糕的回忆录或传记。
Yeah, like any biography where it's just that's hagiography, right?
没错，任何那种传记，那叫圣徒传，对吧？
Is that like how they describe like the lives of saints like no one's that interested in reading?
那是他们描述圣徒生平的方式吗？就是那种没人有兴趣读的东西？
How it all went great like we want to hear struggle.
一切都进展得非常顺利，我们想听的是挣扎。
We want to and you trust a narrator When they actually Jason's really great at telling stories where he's kind of the butt of the joke Like he loves it when he has been humiliated like he loves telling those stories.
我们想听，而且当你信任一位叙述者时……杰森真的很擅长讲那些他自己成为笑柄的故事，他喜欢自己出糗的时刻，他很喜欢讲那些故事。
I always admired that about him He's really good at telling stories where he doesn't look that great in the story, but him telling it is charming and you forgive him whatever his behavior was because he's willing to share it.
我一直很钦佩他这一点，他非常擅长讲那些他自己看起来并不怎么样的故事，但他讲出来时却很有魅力，你会原谅他之前的任何行为，因为他愿意分享。
It's almost like one of the things, this is going deep in the weeds, but one of the reasons that the Torah, the Old Testament, was a revolutionary kind of earthquake and narrative is because Every story of a people was written by the victors, and it was written about how great everyone was.
这有点像——这话题扯远了——但《托拉》（旧约）之所以能成为一种革命性的叙事地震，原因之一就是，每一个民族的故事都是由胜利者书写的，写的都是大家有多么伟大。
And the Torah and the story of this little tribe that got knocked around is just one idiotic move after another.
而《托拉》以及这个饱受磨难的小部落的故事，却是一连串愚蠢的举动。
Like they really cataloged their own folly, right?
他们真的记录了自己的愚行，对吧？
And their own, and how they didn't listen to the law or this way, and they didn't, you know, And it's maybe it's endured because it's honest.
还有他们如何不听从律法，以及诸如此类的事情，也许它能流传至今是因为它足够诚实。
And it's not, hey, geography.
它不是圣徒传。
It's, I think we trust people.
我认为我们信任他人。
You, when I hear, when you list your accomplishments, you breed competition.
当你列举自己的成就时，你滋生的是竞争。
When you lead with vulnerability, you breed community, you know?
当你以脆弱示人时，你建立的是社区，你懂吗？
Yes.
是的。
So I think, you know, even though Ted, sometimes you can go like, oh God, why won't this guy get it together?
所以我认为，即使有时你会觉得，天哪，这家伙为什么就不能振作起来呢？
It's actually his superpower.
这其实是他的超能力。
that he is leading with, here's another way I messed up.
他总是先说：这是我搞砸的另一件事。
Oh my God, let me tell you about this night.
天哪，让我告诉你那天晚上的事。
I really put my foot in my mouth.
我真的说错话了。
Let me tell you this.
让我告诉你这个。
Future dad is the embodiment of this.
未来的爸爸就是这种特质的化身。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Like it's all getting dinged up.
就像一切都在磕磕碰碰中前行。
And in some ways, that's actually, it's occurring to me now, it's an incredibly loving thing to tell your children when they're ready to hear.
在某种程度上，我现在意识到，当孩子们准备好倾听时，告诉他们这些其实是一件非常有爱的事情。
I'm an imperfect human being, your dad just grew up.
我是一个不完美的人，你爸爸也是这样长大的。
But also, he landed on his feet and he did okay.
但同时，他最终站稳了脚跟，做得还不错。
So I think it's a great observation that there's a kind of microcosm, macrocosm thing going on here that Jordana pointed out.
所以我认为乔丹娜指出的那种微观与宏观的联系是一个非常棒的观察。
Yeah, it's a great observation.
是的，这是一个很棒的观察。
It's my wife's smart.
我老婆很聪明。
Your wife's really smart.
你老婆真的很聪明。
She's really good.
她真的很厉害。
You should hold on to that one.
你应该好好珍惜她。
Whether or not she's officially a relationship expert, I think you should keep her around.
不管她是不是正式的心理咨询专家，我觉得你都应该留住她。
I think she's maybe a really, I think she's really weird.
我觉得她可能真的很……我觉得她真的很特别。
Whether or not she's officially your wife.
不管她是不是你名义上的妻子。
And I was like, yeah, she's officially my wife.
我当时就说，是的，她确实是我名义上的妻子。
Back off, man.
离远点，伙计。
Well, that was super fun, Craig, going deep on that episode.
好吧，克雷格，深入探讨那一集真是太有趣了。
I really enjoyed that.
我很享受这次交流。
I like that one.
我喜欢那一集。
Yeah, it's a good one.
是的，那是一集好作品。
Isn't it funny that we're gonna have favorite episodes of this show that won't necessarily correspond to our favorite episodes of How I Met Your Mother?
有趣的是，我们在这个节目中会有最喜欢的剧集，但这未必对应我们最喜欢的《老爸老妈浪漫史》剧集，你不觉得吗？
They're just like, the conversation, it led somewhere cool, right?
它们就像是，对话，引向了一些很酷的地方，对吧？
Like it'll be.
就像它会那样。
Himium episode was garbage, but this podcast episode was really fun.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》那一集很烂，但这一期播客很有趣。
The circuits were jammed though.
不过线路堵塞了。
The circuits were jammed.
线路堵塞了。
If we can't get anything going, like we're just like the circuits are jammed.
如果我们什么都做不了，就像我们说的线路堵塞了。
The circuits are just jammed today.
今天线路就是堵塞了。
Look, that's New Year's Eve for ya.
看，这就是除夕夜。
You're welcome, but for that turn of phrase.
不客气，为了那个措辞。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, we like to end our episode with some viewer listener male and we have a lovely letter today from Jessica and Craig is going to read it for us.
好吧，我们喜欢以听众来信结束我们的节目，今天我们收到了一封来自杰西卡的可爱信件，克雷格将为我们朗读。
Yes, this is lovely and a little conversation talking point emerges at the end of it.
是的，这很可爱，结尾还出现了一个小小的谈话要点。
So here we go, ready?
那么我们开始吧，准备好了吗？
This is Jessica from Jessica.
这是来自杰西卡的信。
She says, Hi, Josh and Craig.
她说，嗨，乔什和克雷格。
Jessica here from New Brunswick, Canada, shout out to Canada.
我是来自加拿大新不伦瑞克省的杰西卡，向加拿大问好。
We love our Canadian fans and we love our Canadian characters as a plural?
我们爱我们的加拿大粉丝，我们也爱我们的加拿大角色，复数形式？
I think we had a few over the years.
我想这些年来我们有几个。
My husband Tristan introduced me to him when we first started dating and it quickly became a cherished part of our lives.
我丈夫特里斯坦在我们刚开始约会时向我介绍了这部剧，它很快就成了我们生活中珍贵的一部分。
The show holds such significance to us that it actually played a role in our wedding day.
这部剧对我们意义重大，它甚至在我们的婚礼当天发挥了作用。
From gifting my soon-to-be husband a blue French horn to open the morning of the wedding to having Heaven by the Walkman play during our recessional Great Song.
从在婚礼当天早上送给我未来的丈夫一支蓝色法国号，到在我们的退场仪式上播放《Walkmen》乐队的《Heaven》——很棒的歌。
You have to wait till the end of the series, you get to it.
你得等到剧集最后，你就会看到了。
and the unforgettable moment of our bosses surprising us with a cameo of Josh during our heartfelt speech.
还有我们老板在我们的感人演讲中惊喜地播放了乔什的客串视频，那真是令人难忘的时刻。
I know cameos might seem like a small gesture to celebrities, but hearing Josh say, as Ted Mosby said, love is the best thing we do on our wedding day, was nothing short of legendary, captured beautifully in the photos and video footage of our reactions.
我知道对于名人来说，客串可能只是一个小小的举动，但听到乔什说，正如泰德·莫斯比所说，爱是我们所做的最好的事情，在我们的婚礼当天，这简直是传奇，我们的反应被照片和视频片段完美地捕捉了下来。
Please send us those, by the way, Jessica.
顺便说一下，杰西卡，请把那些发给我们。
It warms my heart to see how both of you remain humbled and perhaps a touch astonished by the profound impact your creation has had on countless lives.
看到你们俩依然保持谦逊，甚至对你们的作品给无数人带来的深远影响感到一丝惊讶，这让我倍感温暖。
My question for both of you is this.
我想问你们俩一个问题。
Is there a show or film series that evokes the same feelings in you that Himyum does for its fans?
有没有哪部剧或电影系列能让你们产生和《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝们一样的感受？
I eagerly anticipate this journey of dissecting every last episode.
我非常期待这次剖析每一集的旅程。
Please know that you both and Carter have conjured something truly spectacular, a treasure that will continue to resonate for years to come.
请相信，你们和卡特共同创造了一些真正壮观的东西，这是一份将在未来多年里持续产生共鸣的宝藏。
Thank you, Jessica.
谢谢你，杰西卡。
Well, thanks Jessica.
嗯，谢谢你，杰西卡。
What a lovely, every part of that, being part of their wedding.
真是太美好了，能成为他们婚礼的一部分。
I love that you did that cameo.
我很喜欢你做了那个客串视频。
Did you, I don't know if you remember doing that specific one years ago or not.
我不知道你是否还记得几年前做的那个特定的视频。
And did you know what was going to be part of a wedding?
而且你知道那会成为婚礼的一部分吗？
I don't, I'm, I mean, I get asked to do weddings.
我不记得了，我是说，我确实会被邀请去参加婚礼。
I always make a joke about being underdressed.
我总是会开个玩笑说自己穿得太随便了。
That's kind of my, um, but yeah, I mean, I, sometimes they'll say, can you throw in a Ted Mosby quote, you love.
那是我的惯用伎俩，嗯，但确实，有时他们会说，你能加一句你喜欢的泰德·莫斯比的台词吗？
And for me, that's like the one, you know, from, uh, for a wedding.
对我来说，那就是婚礼上最合适的一句。
I think that's the, the best one.
我觉得那是最好的一句。
Yeah.
是的。
It's the whole series, right?
这是整部剧的核心，对吧？
that if you had to distill the series down to one line, that could be in the running to be the one.
如果必须把整部剧浓缩成一句台词，那句台词很有可能就是候选者。
And I think there's different kinds of love, like we have that one word, but like C.S.
而且我认为爱有不同的种类，虽然我们只有一个词来表达，但像C.S.刘易斯写过一本叫《四种爱》的书，对吧？
Lewis has a book called The Four Loves, right?
里面提到了爱欲、友爱等等，有很多种，但我认为广义上的爱是它如何体现的，因为剧中肯定有友谊之爱。
It's like Eros and Philos and, like there's different, but I think love more broadly speaking is kind of how it may or not, because there's certainly friendship, love.
这很大程度上是关于友谊的。
It's so much about friendship.
It's mostly that, right?
基本上就是这样，对吧？
In the end, it's a lot of dates, but the friendships there the whole time.
最后，虽然约会了很多次，但友谊却始终贯穿其中。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you have pieces of art that live and take residence in your heart the way that Hemium has for these fans?
你有没有像《Hemium》对这些粉丝那样，在心中占据一席之地的艺术作品？
I mean, for me, I feel like what Jessica's talking about, and I think the feeling she's talking about can only be achieved through a franchise, a series, something that goes on a while that you can spend that much time with.
我是说，对我而言，我觉得杰西卡所说的，以及她提到的那种感觉，只有通过系列作品、连续剧，或者某种能让你花很长时间陪伴的东西才能实现。
Your favorite movie that's like an hour and a half long, two hours long, you can go back into that world over and over, but it's kind of always that one thing.
你最喜欢的电影可能只有一两个小时长，你可以一遍又一遍地回到那个世界，但它始终是那个样子。
It's hard to replicate that what she's talking about, what a TV series can give you.
很难复制她所说的电视剧能带给你的那种体验。
It's such a gift to get nine seasons to do a show.
能有九季的剧集真的是一种馈赠。
So for me, what comes up for me when she says that is like Star Wars.
所以对我来说，当她说这话时，我想到的是《星球大战》。
The Star Wars franchise just getting to that stretching across my entire childhood into my adult life.
《星球大战》系列跨越了我的整个童年，一直延伸到我的成年生活。
The Harry Potter books and movies give me some of that feeling.
《哈利·波特》系列书籍和电影也给了我一些那种感觉。
And then sitcom wise, you know, what made me want of right sitcoms was was Cheers mostly the show Cheers Buffy gave me some of that in my 20s and led into the show and casting Alice and had again and it's funny I had one other thing that came up for me from her question was I just watched the Conan O'Brien Mark Twain prize show on Netflix which is great.
至于情景喜剧，你知道，让我想要创作情景喜剧的原因主要是《欢乐酒店》，《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》在我二十多岁时也给了我一些那种感觉，并引导我进入了演艺圈，还选角了爱丽丝……有趣的是，关于她的问题，我脑海中还浮现出另一件事，我刚在Netflix上看了柯南·奥布莱恩的马克·吐温奖颁奖典礼，非常棒。
Is that where everybody brings their A-game in that Feral so funny I saw that clip.
是那个每个人都拿出看家本领的节目吗？威尔·法瑞尔太搞笑了，我看了那个片段。
Will Feral so funny watch it watch the whole thing it's It's all killer, no filler.
威尔·法瑞尔太搞笑了，一定要看，看完整版，全是精华，没有废话。
It's like everybody comes and brings their A-game because they love Conan so much.
就像每个人都因为太爱柯南而拿出了最好的状态。
And why am I bringing that up?
我为什么要提这个？
It's because watching that made me realize how much Conan O'Brien has meant to me from 1993 premiering at Dave Letterman's old slot.
因为看那个节目让我意识到，从1993年他在大卫·莱特曼的老档期首播以来，柯南·奥布莱恩对我有多重要。
Dave Letterman, a lot to me too.
大卫·莱特曼对我来说也很重要。
I wrote for Dave Letterman a few years after that.
那之后几年我还为大卫·莱特曼写过稿子。
I wanted to write for Conan.
我曾想为柯南写稿。
Carter and I both really were angling to write for Conan.
卡特和我当时都非常渴望能为柯南写稿。
And we got, they were not hiring, but Letterman was incredibly lucky.
我们当时没赶上招聘，但能为莱特曼工作已经非常幸运了。
and I love Letterman equally as much in a different way.
我同样以另一种方式热爱着莱特曼。
But Conan, just watching the Netflix special about his sort of totality of his career, I felt like emotional watching it because I'm like this, I just feel like I've lived 30 years with this guy.
但看着关于柯南职业生涯全貌的Netflix特辑，我感到很动情，因为我觉得自己和这家伙一起生活了30年。
And I got this brief little intersection with him where he came and spoilers.
我曾有过一次与他短暂交集的机会，当时他来客串，剧透一下。
It was a background extra and an episode of How Much A Mother.
我当时在《老爸老妈浪漫史》的一集中当背景群演。
We will explain that more when we get to it many years from now.
等很多年后我们讲到那一集时，会再详细解释。
And after that, he knew that Carter and I were big fans and he asked us to, we asked him to lunch.
在那之后，他知道卡特和我都是他的忠实粉丝，于是他邀请我们去吃午饭。
And so a few weeks later, we got to spend a couple hours having lunch with Conan, and it was just, I just had this feeling in watching it, I think is what Jessica's talking about, which is you just can't, not many things can give you the feeling that you spent your whole life with somebody.
几周后，我们和柯南一起吃了几个小时的午餐，看节目时我就是那种感觉，我想这就是杰西卡所说的，很少有东西能给你那种“你和某人共度了一生”的感觉。
You've spent years and years and years in this world or with this energy, and so I'm so happy that Hemium was that to her.
你在那个世界里，或者与那种能量共处了多年，所以我很高兴《Hemium》对她来说就是那样的存在。
What is it for you, Josh?
对你来说是什么呢，乔什？
What comes up to you for you of that?
你脑海中浮现的是什么？
Like, what have I held with me this over cross, across such a long time?
比如，有什么东西是我在这么长的时间里一直珍藏的？
Yeah, well, we've talked about the movie Sing Street, which is one of my favorite movies.
嗯，我们聊过《初恋无限Touch》，那是我最喜欢的电影之一。
I've just seen so much of it.
我已经看过很多遍了。
I love that movie.
我爱那部电影。
I just re-watched that movie.
我刚又重温了一遍。
I bet Elliott likes that movie too.
我敢说艾略特也会喜欢那部电影。
Has he seen it?
他看过吗？
Ah, he hasn't seen that.
啊，他还没看过。
Yeah, that would be a great one to watch.
是的，那会是一部很棒的电影。
I think he.
我想他会……
What a music movie.
多么棒的音乐电影啊。
One of the great music movies.
最伟大的音乐电影之一。
And great brother movies.
也是很棒的兄弟题材电影。
Yeah, it just works on all levels for me.
是的，它在各个层面上都深得我心。
Hell, I'll let you know.
嘿，我会让你知道的。
I'm a huge fan of the before trilogy, the link letter.
我是理查德·林克莱特《爱在》三部曲的超级粉丝。
See, that's a trilogy.
看，那才叫三部曲。
Because you have years and years that spans 15 years, those three movies.
因为那三部电影跨越了整整15年的时间。
and you get to watch them age, which is always so moving to watch people get older.
你可以看着他们变老，看着人们逐渐老去总是让人非常动容。
And I just think there's something, he really catches something in those movies.
我觉得他确实在那些电影里捕捉到了一些特别的东西。
The last one's almost like impossible to watch in some ways, because it's so tragic, but also so beautiful.
最后一部在某些方面几乎让人无法直视，因为它太悲剧了，但也太美了。
But I love those, I'm trying to think, I mean, there's certain authors that I, just I'm always coming back to, I've talked about this before, but Nick Cave does this weekly, it's called The Red Hand Files, And he just answers kind of like, reader, male, and he's, he's the most beautiful writer.
但我很喜欢那些，我在想，我是说，有些作者我总是会反复阅读，我之前也提到过，尼克·凯夫每周都会写一个专栏，叫《红手档案》，他只是回答读者的来信，他真的是一位非常出色的作家。
He's really funny.
他真的很幽默。
And it's reliably the best thing I read every week.
这绝对是我每周读到的最好的内容。
And I feel like I get to sit around this campfire with Nick Cave and have him tell.
我觉得自己就像坐在尼克·凯夫身边的篝火旁，听他讲述。
He wrote one today that was so funny about him and Nick Cage getting confused.
他今天写了一篇关于他和尼克·凯奇被搞混的趣事，特别好笑。
And he was drinking with this guy whose wife was leaving him.
当时他正和一个妻子要离开他的男人喝酒。
And he was like, my wife loves you, man.
那个人说，伙计，我妻子很喜欢你。
I need to tell her.
我得告诉她。
realized he thought he was Nick Cage, the actor, not Nick Cage, the rock star.
后来才意识到那个人以为他是演员尼克·凯奇，而不是摇滚明星尼克·凯夫。
So he ends up writing an autograph for her, and he ends up talking about raising Arizona was a tough shoot, but the Cone Brothers is so great, and he was so drunk, just imitating Nick Cage.
于是他最后给她写了签名，还聊起《抚养亚利桑那》拍摄过程很艰苦，但科恩兄弟真的很棒，他当时喝得烂醉，一直在模仿尼克·凯奇。
But I love those so much, and I think the campfires I tend to gravitate around are a little more probably movies or books, but you know, I grew up watching Cheers and Family Ties and that, you know, that Thursday lineup, that night court LA law, I mean, so I feel, I watched so much more TV when I was a kid than I do now, much to my wife, Sugarin.
但我非常喜欢这些，我觉得我倾向于围坐的“篝火”可能更多是电影或书籍，但你知道，我从小看《干杯酒吧》和《家族纽带》长大，还有周四晚上的节目阵容，比如《夜间法庭》和《洛城法网》，所以我觉得，我小时候看的电视比现在多得多，我妻子对此很有意见。
But yeah, I mean, I don't think anyone gets in this business that we're in without having things that have really taken up residence in their psyche, you know?
但确实，我觉得没有人能在我们这一行立足，除非他们心里装了一些真正扎根于灵魂深处的东西，你懂吗？
And I'm sure we'll end this, and I'll think of eight more in one of those.
我肯定等节目结束了，我还会想到八个这样的例子。
Well, I think you hit the nail on the head by saying the word campfire.
嗯，我觉得你说到“篝火”这个词真是点睛之笔。
I think Jessica feels like she was around this campfire with us for all these years.
我觉得杰西卡一定觉得这些年来她一直和我们围坐在篝火旁。
We're all telling stories.
我们都在讲故事。
And I think it's such a gift to have that campfire kind of burn for as many, for enough years to sort of tell enough stories around.
而且我觉得能让这堆篝火燃烧这么多年，讲足够多的故事，这真是一份礼物。
And I think it's so rare to get to do that.
我觉得能做到这一点非常难得。
That's why my brain went to like things I've spent lots of time with.
这就是为什么我的大脑会想到那些我花了很多时间陪伴的东西。
I think that's what she's talking about.
我想这就是她所说的。
So yeah, thank you Jessica for the question.
所以，谢谢杰西卡的提问。
Thank you for spending that much time with us around the campfire.
谢谢你花这么多时间陪我们围坐在篝火旁。
And this new campfire too.
还有这堆新的篝火。
So thank you.
所以，谢谢你们。
I am guilty, please equip me.
我有罪，请宽恕我。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪过都会被原谅。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《How We Made Your Mother》由乔什·拉德诺和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由Office Ladies Network和Odyssey出品并发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金赛。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
节目由我，亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是Point of Blue Studios的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师，是艾米丽·布伦伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
美术设计由约翰·莫罗负责。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在Apple Podcasts或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分并评论本节目。
That really does help the show.
这对节目真的很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲由乔什·拉德诺创作，额外音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问HowWeMajorMother.com了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是节目中重要的一部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
订阅乔什·拉德诺在Substack上的通讯，并在joshradner.com查看他的音乐及其他作品。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的首部小说《That's Not How It Happened》，并访问CraigThomasWriter.com查看他发表的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在Substack上订阅我自己的《Dead Fathers Society》。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于我们如何做出改变，以及本节目为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹款的持续活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”标签。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们确实会跳舞。